Ja, willkommen! Hallo! Und was gibt's da für Begrüßungsoptionen? Oh, Dennis? Was sagt Darth Vader zur Begrüßung?
Nee, der Imperator kommt.
Ich bin euer Vater! Ihr hört es schon an den Tönen. Es ist heimlich, es ist gemütlich, es ist Zeit für Mobile Max auf euren Kopfhörern. Oder wo auch immer ihr gerade das Audiosignal hingeleitet habt. Wir begrüßen auch wieder die Live-Chat-Runde, die uns hier immer virtuell unterstützt, begleitet, verfolgt. Und ja, wir begrüßen Dennis. Hallo Dennis!
Hallo!
Schön, dass du wieder da bist.
Ich war gar nicht weg.
Aber du hast geschlafen, du warst im Arsch.
Ja, nee, dann nicht, aber... Ich war out of sync, nenn ich das immer.
Okay, du warst im Fnord. Das ist doch gut. Da muss man auch manchmal hin. Mir geht das ähnlich.
Nee, aber toll ist anders.
Ja, wir haben uns wacker geschlagen. Hast du denn die Sendung überhaupt gehört?
Achso, nee, wollte ich, hab ich vergessen.
Oh Mann.
Aber ihr habt gesagt, die war eh doof.
Quatsch, die war total toll. Die war super.
Ich weiß, ihr habt gesagt, ihr habt gar nichts bequatscht und irgendwie hab ich euch gefehlt, habt ihr gesagt.
Hunderte Leute haben gesagt, sie wollen jetzt eigentlich nur noch uns beide hören.
Von unseren Zehntausenden, von Zuhörern.
Naja, wie auch immer. Jetzt sind wir auf jeden Fall mal wieder komplett und zwar auch jetzt seit über einem Monat das erste Mal so richtig live und in Farbe. Und das ist ja auch ganz gut so, denn es ist ja so viel nicht passiert, über das wir unbedingt reden müssen. Oder? Also ich meine, die Nachrichtenlage ist lame, finde ich. Also gut, man könnte jetzt irgendwie stundenlang über iLive reden, aber mal ehrlich, habt ihr schon viel Zeit damit verbracht?
Ich hab die Gesichtserkennung trainiert, ohne Ende.
Also bis auf den Erdhörn hab ich damit noch nichts verbracht.
Du hast es also auch noch nicht installiert oder so?
Nee. Es ist ja ein Virus drin eventuell.
Das könnte sein. War das nicht iWork?
Auch, ja. Auch?
Na, es könnte nicht überall ein Virus drin sein.
Ja, irgendwie weiß ich nicht. Dieses i-Foto, das macht immer gleich so einen Riesenalarm. Und irgendwie sind meine Bilder inzwischen auch so viel Platten verteilt, ich müsste erst mal konsolidieren.
Tja, also ich hab da noch wirklich keine, ich kann da noch nicht so viel zu sagen. Also das Maps-Interface war mir jetzt so auf den ersten Blick zu wenig ausführlich. Also man konnte da immer so stete Einträgen, aber so wie ich mir denken würde, hat das nicht funktioniert. Aber ich hab so wenig damit gearbeitet, dass es eigentlich total müßig ist, da drüber zu reden. Ich glaube, wenn man sich das irgendwie im Detail geben will, dann soll man irgendwie mal hier letzte Folge von Bits und so, die haben das mal wieder so bis in den letzten Pixel durchanalysiert, was da funktioniert und was da nicht funktioniert. Da kann ich nur die Waffen strecken. Naja, also ich hab halt gestern Abend das erste Mal damit gespielt. Und dann bin ich müde geworden. Also von daher kann ich da nicht so sehr viel zu sagen.
Mir ist aufgefallen, wie unglaublich viele Namen von Verwandten mir nicht eingefallen sind, die auf den Fotos abgebildet waren und den ich theoretisch hätte Namen zuordnen sollen. Und in dem Moment sieht man das, also drei Stunden später ist es dann überhaupt kein Problem mehr. Aber in dem Moment, in dem ich davor sitze, sind mir die Namen nicht eingefallen. Das ist echt das iLife. Da warte ich auf iLife 10.
Ach du meinst, da muss auch noch eine Namenserkennung drin haben?
Am besten schon, ja klar.
Du siehst aus wie Peter.
Du könntest so ein Peter sein. Naja, der Facebook-Abgleich, der wird ja bestimmt noch eines Tages kommen, dass man dann so alles klar Gesicht erkannt, welche Person ist das denn, dann automatisch verbunden.
Leute, die so aussehen wie du, heißen Peter. Oh Gott, wir müssen schon mal über allen Peters, die jetzt hier zuhören, entschuldigen.
Das ist das neue Amazon-Feature.
Das war jetzt einfach nur ein Generic-Example. Ja, aber vielleicht, bevor wir mit den ganzen neuen Sachen anfangen, über die wir nichts wissen, nochmal einen Blick zurück. Dennis, wir hatten ja da so eine Sendung, du erinnerst dich, wo ich irgendwie über mein Drobo geklagt habe und wir so viel über ZFS geschwatzt haben.
Ich erinnere mir.
Und das hat ja richtig Welle gemacht. Da gab es ja richtig Feedback. Und ja, dann konnten wir aber so letzte Sendung irgendwie nicht so richtig die ZFS-Diskussion fortsetzen, weil es hagelte ja Kommentare ohne Ende zu spezifischen Lösungen, wo sozusagen Leute ZFS als Nass bereits aufgesetzt haben oder vorhaben, das zu tun oder keine Ahnung, Spezifikationen runtergehängt haben und so weiter. Hast du dir da irgendwas mal näher angeschaut, was da so...
Also was halt das Problem ist, dass der Time Machine an sich nur mit einem HFS funktionieren will. Das heißt, man kann Time Machine zum Beispiel nicht zwingen auf einen ZFS zu Backup, sondern dass wir immer einen HFS haben. Das heißt, wenn du... Es gibt so einen Default-Ride, wo man sagen kann, dass das Time Machine auch Volumes supportet, die halt nicht Time Capsule oder eine Express-Station sind oder halt lokal, dann kann man auch Remote halt irgendwie auf Storage speichern lassen. Aber der will da halt seinen HFS haben und deswegen legt er dann los und speichert dort ein Disk-Image ab. Und das wiederum hat auf ZFS nicht funktioniert und er sagt einfach, er konnte das Disk-Image nicht anlegen. Das kann man wohl wieder umgehen, indem man es selber anlegt und dort ablegt, dann nimmt er das Fertige. Aber ich meine, wir wollen ja auch nicht, dass hier alle User so total tief rumbasteln. Das soll ja was sein, was einfach funktioniert. Also bisher gibt es da noch nicht so richtig chic die Lösung.
Ja stimmt, er macht ja auf Remote, macht sowieso immer ein Disk-Image und schreibt da selber rein. Ja, also ich komme auch so zunehmend in Maße dahin.
Also egal wie man es dreht, das Time Machine will halt einen HFS Plus haben und das ist einfach immer blöd. Das muss dazwischen weg, finde ich.
Ja, das muss auch weg.
Weil wenn das kaputt ist, sind deine Daten auch gleich alle weg. Okay, also Gott sei Dank, weil es vielleicht schon so alt ist, gibt es halt tausende Tools, die es irgendwie reparieren können, wie DiskWare und so weiter und so fort. Aber eigentlich will man es trotzdem nicht.
Ja, es sei denn du hast ein Drobo, wobei da ist irgendwie die Situation so ein bisschen unklar. Mir sind da so verschiedene Specs über den Weg gekommen. Also vielleicht nochmal zur Erfahrung mit dem Teil. Also so jetzt habe ich das Ding, nachdem ich das ja neu aufgesetzt hatte, habe ich den jetzt an meine Time Capsule angeschlossen und das Ding ist quasi nur noch so remote und dann eben quasi an das Teil mit USB schön langsam angeschlossen. Das funktioniert soweit mit Einschränkungen. Was mir nämlich jetzt schon zweimal, also mir ist das schon letztes Mal einmal passiert gewesen, aber da habe ich diesen Effekt nicht so richtig zur Kenntnis genommen oder nicht zur Kenntnis nehmen wollen, glaube ich, jetzt ist es mir nochmal passiert. Ich habe den Drobo an meinem Rechner angeschlossen gehabt, dann war ich fertig, abgezogen, dann rübergetragen, an die Time Machine angeschlossen, eingeschaltet und dann kamen wir auch hoch, aber es kamen nur drei von den vier Platten hoch. Und dann brauchen wir erstmal eine Weile, bis man das so schneit, weil man hat ja immer Hoffnung, dass die Lampe dann irgendwann nochmal angeht, aber die vierte war dann halt einfach aus. So und bevor ich da auch irgendwie interagieren konnte, weil wir so einen Schrank gestellt haben, man geht ja nicht davon aus, dass es jetzt irgendwie gleich so losgeht, fing er dann halt sofort an, Panik zu schieben, dahingehend, dass ihm halt eine Platte fehlt und fing halt mit dem Resilvering an. Hat also da quasi seine...
Worauf denn?
Na auf die anderen drei Platten. Also er hat ja sozusagen den gesamten Datenbestand, aber schreibt ja dann alles so um, dass er fortab nur noch mit drei Platten redundant ist, dass man sozusagen auch noch eine dritte rausnehmen könnte. Das senkt halt den zur Verfügung stehenden...
Also eine ausfällt, hat man sozusagen keine Renundanz mehr, deswegen schreibt alles einmal so um, dass die Renundanz wieder da ist.
Genau. Und er ist aber auch richtig mit beschäftigt. Naja, nur weiß ich mal so, warum, warum, warum. Mir war das jetzt einfach mal total unklar, warum diese Platten... Es war auch derselbe Slot, der unterste. Vielleicht liegt es ja auch an dem Slot, ich hab keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall ist das auch so ein Ding, er fing halt schon mal damit an. Dann hab ich das Ding wieder ausgeschaltet. Das ist natürlich auch so ein schwieriges, so ein schwieriger Moment ist, wo man sich denkt so, ah, okay. Ich hab da jetzt so ein Half S Plus und das Ding macht jetzt gerade so Panikkopien irgendwie so. Und ich schalt ihn jetzt einfach so aus, weil runterfahren, ordnungsgemäßes runterfahren in dem Sinne geht ja nicht an so einem Embedded Device, so wenn ich das hinten an so einer Time Capsule ranballer. Naja, dann hab ich, oder warte mal, hab ich den überhaupt ausgeschaltet? Nee, was ich gemacht habe, ist, ich hab die Festplatte rausgenommen und wieder reingesteckt. Genau. So. Und das hatte dann auch den entsprechenden Erfolg. Dann hat er sie wieder erkannt. Jetzt möchte man ja meinen, dass er dann so, ah, da ist ja die Platte, und dann irgendwie wieder schnell klarkommt. Aber er war dann noch, ich hab's nicht genau gemessen, aber es war, glaub ich fast, er war fast den ganzen Tag damit beschäftigt, einen Normalzustand wieder herzustellen. Das heißt, das Ding war einfach die ganze Zeit laut, alle vier Platten leuchteten irgendwie orange und er war wirklich 24 Stunden mindestens damit beschäftigt, den Normalzustand wieder herzustellen.
Na ja, aber ich meine, er muss auch erstmal checken, ob die Daten überhaupt noch stimmen auf der Platte und ob die wirklich noch hoch wieder hochgekommen ist und so. Das ist schon irgendwo nachvollziehbar.
Kann er das dann überhaupt checken?
Bestimmt nicht.
Na aber er muss ja in der Lage sein, aufgrund der Renundance, dir hat zu überprüfen, welche Daten müssten auf der Platte drauf sein.
Das heißt nur, dass er einen Block nicht kriegt, dann nimmt er halt den anderen. Aber ob die korrekt sind, ist noch ein anderes Thema.
Also, dass der Drobo CheckSum macht, das will mir neu und ich bezweifle das. Aber, also wissen tu ich es nicht, aber gehört hab ich davon auch nichts. Und generell hab ich eigentlich von CheckSum noch nirgendswo was gehört, außer bei ZFS. Naja, das nun mal so noch als Nachtrag. Das muss jetzt auch nichts unbedingt Schlechtes bedeuten. Ist halt nur so, dass ich mich frage, wenn jetzt das Ding einmal, also warum, wie kann es sein, dass er diese Platte nicht erkennt? Zweitens, also warum meldet er sich nicht mit, da müsste eigentlich noch eine vierte Platte sein, kannst du sie nicht mal reinlegen?
Weil du ja vielleicht gerade nicht da bist und er muss ja auch selber handeln.
Ja, dann kann er mir ja zumindest eine Minute Zeit geben. Er kann ja mal 60 Sekunden lang das Ding orange blinken lassen, blink. Hier müsste eigentlich eine Platte sein. Und wenn ich mir denke, die ist drin, dann vielleicht nochmal richtig rein rausgehen.
Wenn der Vorgang eh 24 Stunden dauert, dann macht die eine Minute das auch nicht mehr aus.
Exakt. So war's. Fände ich auf jeden Fall schon mal ganz brauchbar. Und ich frage mich halt auch dann, in dem Moment, wo dann die Platte doch wieder da ist, warum es dann so, also was tut er da eigentlich? Also ich meine, 24 Stunden? Was?
Meinst du, dass er auf den Fall vorbereitet ist? Und nicht einfach nur sagt, alles klar, ich hab ja eine neue Platte endlich wieder. Ich kann mit den Daten, die ich eigentlich auf drei Platten gerade aufteilen wollte, die kann ich jetzt wieder auf vier und hat einfach die vierte gelöscht und die mit in den Cluster mit reinbezogen.
Das kann gut sein. Das kann gut sein, dass er diese ganze Platte komplett neu aufgebaut hat.
Und das hat er schon mehr als einmal gemacht?
Was hast du dann viermal einen Tag Arbeit, ja?
Also er hat da im Zweifelsfall ein halbes Tee irgendwie noch mal drauf kopiert. Das kann gut sein. Er sagt einem ja auch nicht genau, was er da tut. Ist halt alles orange. Ist halt eine Blackbox, was vor und nach Teile hat. Vielleicht würde so ein kleines Display den Teil ganz gut bekommen, aber naja, wie auch immer. Jetzt waren wir ja...
Da kann man sich aber auch gleich ein richtiges Storage-Ding holen.
Naja, aber was ist ein richtiges Storage-Ding?
Da gab es nicht diese Arena-Teile oder diese Raids von früher, wo man einfach Platten reingeschoben hat und dann hat man gesagt, hier Raid 5 und zack. Und als Anschluss kam dann hinten... Also früher war es immer Skazi irgendwie, aber es gibt es auch mit Sata bestimmt auch inzwischen alles. Jetzt gibt es ja wahrscheinlich nie mit Fire, weil da ist das Problem.
Wär mir jetzt egal. Ich weiß bloß noch nicht genau, was du meinst. Du meinst jetzt einfach nur ein Raid-System.
So ein kleiner Kasten, passend 4, 6, 8 oder weiß ich nicht, wie viele Platten rein. Und ich kenne es halt noch von früher, die hatten dann halt irgendwie so einen ultra-weit, hast du nicht gesehen, dicken SCSI-Anschluss. Und den hast du halt an deinen Rechner herangemacht. Und dein Rechner hat das Ding als eine Platte gesehen. Und das ist ja fast so ein bisschen wie ein Drobo.
Naja, nur dass du halt beim Drobo noch irgendwie auch schrinken kannst. Du kannst halt eine Platte rausnehmen und draußen lassen sozusagen.
Na die haben da irgendwie so ein virtuelles Block-Device sich gemacht. Deswegen, wenn du eine Platte rausziehst, fallen ihm die Blöcke und dann verteilt das einfach auf die anderen.
So ähnlich würde das funktionieren, denke ich.
Aber gibt es den Drobo dann auch für Windows? Und da machen sie dann auch NTFS, ja? Und gibt es den auch für Linux? Also für andere File-Systems oder nur für die beiden?
Soweit ich weiß, nur die beiden.
Also was mich zum Beispiel ein bisschen wundert ist, du hattest erzählt, dass man, wenn man den Drobo einrichtet, dass man schon vorher sagen muss, wie groß der Maximal ist. Richtig? Und das verstehe ich nicht ganz, weil hier, ich hab mir...
Das File-System.
Weil ich hab mir hier eine 500GB 2,5 Zoll Platte geholt für meinen MacBook, hab das mal ausgetauscht und wollte dann auch XP installieren, weil, mach ich ja normalerweise, ich hab ja mit Windows nix am Hut, aber ich wollte halt mal Halo 2 spielen. Hat alles nicht funktioniert, bis heute nicht. Also Windows ist schuld. Wer sonst? Jedenfalls konnte ich schon meine zweite Position, weil ich hab ja mal zwei und die zweite war dann, keine Ahnung, 450GB groß oder so, konnte die kleiner machen und hinten Platz machen für eine neue Partition. Und konnte die aber auch wieder größer machen, als ich die wieder gelöscht hatte und mir den Platz wiederholen. Also Disk Utility kann live resizen. Resizen, kleiner, größer und so weiter. Deswegen verstehe ich nicht, warum der Drobo da irgendwie vorher das festgelegt haben will. Also die machen doch da ganz üblen Voodoo.
Na gut, die Grenze ist zwei Terabyte.
Ja, auf dem Mac auch hier.
Na, das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, in welchen Grenzen das Disk Utility da rum resizen kann. Auf jeden Fall kann es jetzt resizen. Bloß wenn man halt mit diesen Resize-Operationen an Drobo rangeht, dann ist der Drobo um einmal. Sagt Drobo. Wobei die Aussagen, die jetzt von Drobo kommen, sind auch so ein bisschen durcheinander. Also ich habe jetzt verschiedene Kommentare gelesen, insbesondere in Bezug auf dieses, wodurch kann man jetzt einen Datenverlust wirklich verhindern. Und da gibt es dann die Aussage von Drobo, dass man halt das Ding richtig ordnungsgemäß auswerfen und runterfahren muss, um sicherzustellen, dass das irgendwie alles nicht im Eimer ist. Na ja, da frage ich mich, wie soll ich das Ding an so einem USB-Teil wie der Time Capsule ordnungsgemäß betreiben, weil da kann ich in dem Sinne nicht, da so an diese Funktionalität komme ich so gar nicht ran. Also es ist irgendwie unklar. Es ist wirklich unklar, unter welchen Bedingungen man wirklich safe ist bei diesem Teil. Ich fühle mich da auf jeden Fall nicht so 100%ig wohl. Aber da es derzeit für mich mein Backup von Backup ist, ist es sozusagen...
Nicht so wichtig.
Na ja, ich will nicht sagen, dass es nicht wichtig ist, aber ich weiß, dass es ja schon eine gewisse Renundanz hat. Also auch nur für den Fall, dass eben auch das alles dann nicht mehr funktioniert, dann hätte ich halt unter Umständen Datenverlust. Aber so richtig glücklich bin ich damit noch nicht. Andererseits kann man eben, wie du auch richtig sagst, nicht so ohne weiteres ZDFs jetzt mit Nirodde da mit in den Wing werfen. Bisher noch nicht. Bisher noch nicht, genau. Aber wir kommen der Sache näher. Jetzt waren wir ja alle... Letzte Woche war das. War das letzte Woche?
Das war letzte Woche, genau.
Letzte Woche waren wir in Berlin. Ach, auf einer Veranstaltung.
Ich bin ja hier schon seit Anfang des Jahres.
Die wir schon angekündigt haben. Jetzt keine Spitzfindigkeiten, bitte. Na, wo waren wir?
Ich war bei mir um die Ecke.
Du warst bei dir um die Ecke. Interessante Geoinformation. Wir waren also bei New Thinking und da hat sich zusammengefunden die Open Solaris Berlin User Group oder so. Bro Sook oder so was. Die heißen immer O Sook hintendran. O Sook? Open Solaris User Group. O Sook.
Ach so, O Sook.
Ja, dann kommen dann so Sachen wie Mucko Sook raus.
Nee, München.
Ach so, okay.
Naja, klingt so ein bisschen wie Mucko Fuck.
Ja, mit der Nameswahl haben sie es nicht so.
Ja, und Sook und Suck ist auch ziemlich nah beieinander.
Aber sie können verdammt viel über ZFS erzählen und diskutieren.
Genau. Also Open Solaris User Groups, das ist so ein Vorurteil, was sich bei mir an diesem Abend wieder verfestigt hat, bestehend weitgehend aus Sun-Mitarbeitern. Hattet ihr auch diesen Eindruck? Also ich hatte immer das Gefühl, ich bin bei Sun.
Nee, nur der eine Typ hinten noch.
Nee, da waren mindestens vier. Also der Vortragende, zwei am Rand, die sich auch zurückgehalten haben. Und dann saß noch ganz hinten einer. Und ich weiß nicht, ob es seine Frau, Freundin oder was auch immer war. Und die könnte es auch verdächtigen. Aber sonst der Rest nicht, glaube ich.
Nicht alle, die jetzt da waren. Das frag ich ja nicht. Aber so die Leute, die da den Content bereitgestellt haben. Ja, ich kritisiere das auch nicht. Ich sage nur, das ist so. Aber ich habe jetzt sozusagen unabhängige Experten zu Solaris keine ausmachen können.
Ich sag's direkt neben dir.
Du bist ein Solarisexperte?
Aber der eine, der sich da unten gemeldet hat, der war doch voll der Experte.
Das stimmt. Der wusste viel zu erzählen. Aus dem Klondike und so.
Man darf jetzt hier gar nicht ablösen.
Das ist ja öffentlich so eine Scheiße.
Du kannst qualifiziert deine Meinung äußern.
Wie wär's denn damit?
Qualifiziert Meinung äußern, so weit kommt's noch.
Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall gab es einen Vortrag von einem Sun-Mitarbeiter. Wie gesagt, das ist auch nichts Schlechtes. Die Sun-Mitarbeiter sind völlig in Ordnung. Ich hätte auch nichts dagegen, wenn Apple-Mitarbeiter mal auf der gleichen Ebene Vorträge über Apple-Technologie machen würden. Das wäre sicherlich interessant. Nur sowas wird man nicht finden. Da würdest du auch nicht hingehen. Erdmar hast in Deutschland gar nicht diese Technikfront und zweitens...
Das ist überrannt von so normalen Apple-Fanboys. Da hast du gar keine Chance, in die Tiefe zu gehen.
Was ist überrannt von Apple-Fanboys?
Wenn Apple sowas machen würde.
Die Veranstaltung meinst du jetzt?
Die Besucher? Erstens das, da müsstest du gleich die Arena mieten.
Wir waren doch da bei diesem Tech-Day.
Da waren auch schon ganz schön viele Leute, die einfach nur aus Interesse da waren, hatte ich das Gefühl.
Das ist ja kein Fehler, dass Leute aus Interesse sind.
Doch.
Wieso?
Ich weiß, du musst sie jetzt verteidigen, weil du gehörst dazu, aber... Weil es ist wie mit der Schulklasse, wenn 40 Leute sitzen, kannst du nicht so gut Unterricht machen wie bei 20 Leuten. Wenn da alles nur Leute sind, die es nicht so... Wir wollen mal gucken, Apple ist ganz cool, und außerdem gibt es T-Shirt dahin kommen, dann ist es nicht so schön, als wenn du es in einer kleineren Runde machst. Und bei der Solaris-Gruppe, das war eigentlich eine schöne kleine Runde, das ging.
Obwohl es trotzdem wohl so voll war wie noch nie, nach deren Aussagen, wo man auch mal das gelegen hat.
Das liegt halt daran, dass das Thema ja nicht nur Open Solaris betrifft, sondern halt auch Free BST und Becken-Tosch-Jungs.
Ja, und es ging ja dann auch irgendwie bei Twitter ganz ordentlich rum an dem Tag.
Oder wärst du sonst da gewesen?
Wenn was nicht gewesen wäre.
Wenn es hätte, was nur auf Open Solaris existieren würde und sonst nirgends.
Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Och, das kann ich jetzt... Ich meine, ich hab genau so einen Vortrag schon mal gesehen und den...
Über ZFS oder echt wo?
Auf dem Linux-Tag noch in Wiesbaden. Das ist, glaub ich, drei Jahre her. Das war auch ein Zahn-Mitarbeiter, der war aber...
Wie der ist, der hat sich vor den Linux-Zahnen hingeschaltet und gesagt, guck mal, wir haben einen geilen ZFS, aber nicht für euch.
Tja, so in etwa, ja. Na ja, das war das. Also über Lizenz hab ich mir damals noch keine Gedanken gemacht, aber das... Also ich hab mir den... Wobei ich glaube, ja, ich muss zugeben, das war genau zu dem Zeitpunkt, als das erste Mal dieses Gerücht aufkam, dass Apple Interesse hat an ZFS, weißt du, als diese erste Mail auf einer Mailing-Liste.
Anfang 2007 war das, oder? April 2007?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wann war denn der letzte Linux-Tag in Wiesbaden? Jetzt haben wir 2009, 2007, das kann hinhauen.
Mal gucken.
Ich frag mal. Ah, hier. 2006 war das.
Okay, ein Jahr vorher dann. Ja, kann sein.
Genau, 2006. Und da war auch schon ein sehr, ja, auch so ein Mitarbeiter von Zander und der hat auch einen wohlstrukturierten, extrem umfangreichen Vortrag gemacht. Das war dann so auch erstmal die Basis meines Wissens für eine Weile. Und da waren jetzt, sagen wir mal, bei dem Vortrag letzte Woche für mich auch nur partiell Neuigkeiten.
Ja, also, also, der konnte nichts aus dem Nähkästchen so wirklich erzählen. Keine Ahnung, weiß ja nicht, hat ja nichts erzählt. Also, was für die Zukunft definitiv kommt irgendwie, das Einzige, was er meinte, wo er dann sagte, es hat er jetzt nicht gesagt, ist, dass, dass man halt hier auch Pools kleiner machen kann. Aber, und dass es dieses Jahr kommen soll in irgendeiner Version. Und die Version, von der er redete, waren ja schon immer die offiziellen Solaris-Versionen und nicht diese Express- oder Open Solaris-Versionen.
Genau, das war mal eine Drobo-Frage sozusagen. Ob man diese Drobo-Methodik, dass man eben aus so einem Teil rausnehmen kann.
Da sind die dabei und da gibt es auch schon einen Blog-Eintrag von irgendeinem Typen. Ich glaube, es ist der, der sogar auch Ahrens heißt, so wie ich. Und da schreiben die, dass die halt auch den Scrubbing-Code neu machen. Also der, der eigentlich sozusagen alles durchchecken kann, ob alles okay ist, was man auch fürs Resilvering braucht. Und weil sie den sowieso schon umgeschrieben haben, haben sie dann auch gleich dieses, da werden halt dann Blöcke umkopiert. Das heißt, sagen kannst, die sollen alle Blöcke, die auf dieser Platte sind, verteilt immer auf die anderen Platten, damit die frei ist, damit man sie rausnehmen kann. Da sind die dabei, vielleicht ist es sogar schon fertig. Bei Solaris dauert es dann immer eine Weile, bis es irgendwie das Tageslicht erblickt. Aber dafür funktioniert es dann auch immer gleich sofort. Aber es wird schon kommen, denke ich mal.
Ja, wann kommt denn der Schnee-Leo? Was meint ihr denn?
Also mein Programm, ihr sagt, weil deine Leitung so langsam ist, in zwölf Tagen. Ach nee, Schnee-Leo.
Ich werde nicht von der Version habe ich nicht geredet, sondern von der Final.
Ach so, die...
Meinst du?
Jetzt haben beide meine Zahlen gesagt.
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass das irgendwie so ist. Vielleicht sogar noch einen Monat früher.
Also auf jeden Fall...
Wann ist denn die WWDC? Da hättest du noch gar keinen Termin.
Nö, die ist halt auch so irgendwann da.
Aber seit wann kam denn ein OS zur WWDC raus? Also es wäre ja total blöd, das genau zur WWDC rauszubringen, weil dann ist der Fokus irgendwie komplett auf das neue System.
Das wird's da eh sein.
Jaja, aber dann kannst du es auch schon vorher rausbringen und dann ham's alle oder bringst du es danach raus. Und also die WWDC geht so oder so über Snow Leopard. Das heißt, es sollte den Release...
Also mein Tipp ist, das Ding kommt spätestens mit der WWDC raus, aber idealerweise schon noch einen Monat vorher.
Aber ich weiß jetzt...
Ja, jetzt gibt's keine gesicherten Daten mehr.
Gibt's sowieso nicht.
Es ist jetzt alles aufgelöst irgendwie. Mit der Macworld ist jetzt einfach der letzte Anker. Ist jetzt verschwunden und wir dürfen jetzt von Woche auf Woche hoffen, dass irgendwie ein Mac Mini kommt, dass ein iMac Update kommt, das neue PowerMax. Ich kann auch genau wie ich mal Gigabyte sage, statt Terabyte.
Aber es ist doch auch alles nicht spannend für kleine Speed-Bumps von irgendwelchen Rechnerlinien, finde ich.
Naja, also wenn das Ding jetzt wirklich vier Chores statt zwei hat, dann würde ich das schon nicht mehr so unter Speed-Bump abtun.
Na, doch das ist ein Speed-Bump.
Naja, aber ein signifikanter. Also Verdoppelung finde ich schon ganz ordentlich. Ich hab zum Beispiel die...
Es ist ja nicht wirklich verdoppelt. Du hast mehr Chores. Also ich meine, da musst du schon ganz schön viel Alarm machen, dass du die alle nutzt.
Ich hab die Geschwindigkeit meines Computers verdoppelt.
Indem?
Indem ich ihn neu installiert habe. Das war so nötig.
Du bist ja aber auch ein OS-Kaputtmacher.
Ja, bin ich.
Du bist ja wahrscheinlich auch so ein Typ, der so jeden Scheiß installiert.
Nicht jeden.
Aber einiges. Auf jeden Fall hat sich so einiges angesammelt und ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie alt mein System ist, aber ich schätze mal ungefähr zwei Jahre. Zweieinhalb höchstens.
So ein Jungspund.
Ja, länger hält das bei mir nicht.
Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz intervenieren, weil ich glaube, du hast es vorhin schon angedeutet, wir haben alle so ein blechernes Hintergrundgeräusch, kann das sein? Als wenn jemand, immer wenn ich was sage, irgendwie auf so ein Blech irgendwie mit so einem Schneebesen rumrührt oder sowas.
Ja, das hörst du jetzt ein bisschen extremer, es handelt sich dabei um das Rauschen unserer Computer, was ausgeblendet wird, wenn du nichts sagst. Das ist das, was der Expander macht. Die Alternative wäre, dass es immer da ist. Soll ich dir das mal kurz demonstrieren, wie das sonst wäre?
Oder?
Doch, doch, genau das ist das.
Das ist genau das und das blende ich halt aus, indem ich hier schön meinen Trigger hochblende.
Okay, lass es noch so ein ganz bisschen drin vielleicht.
Ich kann den Trigger ein bisschen niedriger machen.
Kennst du Comfort Noise beim Telefon?
Hab ich jetzt eingeschaltet. Besser?
Comfort Noise hatten wir schon mal gelesen, weil ich wusste nicht, was das ist. Finde ich darum ganz spannend.
Hab ich dir aber ja erklärt, oder?
Hast du das erklärt oder Tim? Auf jeden Fall ist das dieses Hintergrundrauschen, was nur dafür eingeblendet wird, zum Beispiel bei Skype, um, damit man das Gefühl hat, dass die Leitung noch da ist.
Weil eigentlich machen die ja Noise Cancellation, dachten sie, ist voll die tolle Sache und haben es weggemacht. Und dann war immer so, wenn man aufgehört hat, zu sprechen, war...
Dass man immer so, hallo, hallo, bist du da?
Dann war auf einmal das Rauschen weg, weil während der Sprache konnten sie das ja nicht so richtig wegmachen. Dann dachtest du, hä? Dann ist er doch da. Und deswegen haben sie dieses Comfort-Noise eingeführt, damit man sich wieder wohlfühlt.
Ja. Jetzt haben wir auch... Fühlst du dich jetzt auch besser?
Jetzt muss ich so weiter reden. Aber bei dir war es immer, wenn du was sagst, als wenn einer so mit dem Schneebesen auf irgendwie so einen Blechtopf rumreibt oder schlägt oder wie auch immer.
Auf jeden Fall war ich dabei zu erzählen, dass ich meinen Computer neu installiert hab.
Ach ja.
Und ich muss sagen, das war wirklich durchatmen. Also ich hatte hier Zustände auf meinem System.
Also das ganze System und alle Programme.
Das ganze System komplett frisch und jedes Programm, was ich hatte, das heißt du hast auch deinen......neu installiert, aus einem frischen Download.
Dein User-Orden auch komplett neu gemacht.
Nee, ich hab nicht meinen User-Orden erneut gemacht. Ich hab auch tatsächlich ein Großteil meiner Präferenz übernommen. Also meine Prefs hab ich übernommen. Das wär mir dann doch ein bisschen zu viel Arbeit gewesen, wobei ich manche Prefs trotzdem wieder hab neu eingeben müssen. Das ist eben auch so ein bisschen unklar auf dem Mac, wo eigentlich jetzt Programme tatsächlich ihre Settings ablegen. Und das ist irgendwie eine Melange aus, teilweise legen sie es in Library Preferences ab.
Da wo es eigentlich hingehört.
Da gehören ja auch die Einstellungen hin, ja?
Ja, wo es vielleicht hingehört. Das ist aber dann so die große Frage, was da eigentlich alles hingehört.
Deine Einstellung.
Und dann gibt es aber auch noch Library Application Support.
Da gehören ja die Support-Sachen in diesem Programm benutzt.
Was ist denn das?
Nicht deine Einstellung, das ist schon ein Unterschied. Transmission zum Beispiel, das ist mein Lieblingsprogramm von mir. Die speichern da die Resume-Dateien ab und welche Torrents du gerade runterlädst und all sowas. Was ja nicht deine Einstellungen sind, sondern sind mehr so die Daten, mit denen Transmission gerade arbeitet.
Also es liegen sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr viele... Also eigentlich gehören die ja, die Daten, mit denen Transmission so arbeitet, würden doch eigentlich nach Caches gehören, oder?
Den gibt es ja auch noch.
Caches sind nur Sachen, die das Programm braucht, aber nicht unbedingt bei einem Neustart noch da sein müssen.
Also zum Beispiel die Torrens, die du gerade runterlädst, die Torrenfile selber, die liegen da drin.
In Caches?
Nein.
In Application Support. Aber in Application Support liegen durchaus auch Einstellungsdateien. Also bei Firefox zum Beispiel.
Genau, das ist nämlich das Ding. Manche Programme machen das halt einfach anders.
Das sind halt so diese Aliens. Hast du Firefox gesagt gerade?
Ich hab Firefox gesagt, es sind aber auch mehr als nur Firefox.
Die wissen halt nicht, wie es geht.
Naja, aber ich meine, das ist halt das Ding. Man kann dir jetzt natürlich alles vorwerfen, aber wenn du einfach nur dir die Daten auf dem Internet nachdenkst, dann interessiert dich natürlich, dass das alles funktioniert. Du würdest einfach auch gerne mal wissen, wo eigentlich deine Daten nun wirklich sind. Das ist eben nicht so ohne weiteres festzustellen. Naja, wir haben mal. Ich hab auf jeden Fall das so gemacht. So gemacht heißt, ich hab die Prefs alle übernommen und ich hab Application Support selektiv übernommen. Das heißt, ich hab erstmal nichts übernommen. Und dann, wenn ich die Programme installiert habe, gestartet habe, festgestellt habe, dass da irgendwas braun ist, hab ich mir den Ordner auch noch nachgeholt. Teilweise gibt es ja auch Programme, die liegen ihre Sache in Documents ab. Wie zum Beispiel das tolle Programm iChat. Aber das ist ja nur von Apple. Wie sollen die wissen, wie sich ein richtiges Apple-Programm verhält?
Das gibt es immer noch.
Ja, es liegt da einfach seine Chats ab. Aber iChat gehört halt in Documents und ich bin da auch anderer Meinung. Aber erzähl das mal Apple.
Wieso sind die gespeicherten Chats, oder?
Ja, deine Logs.
Find ich jetzt da nicht so komplett unpassend, aber okay.
Ich find die da total unpassend. Ich will überhaupt nicht, dass überhaupt irgendein Programm selber irgendwas in Documents reinschreibt, weil das sind meine Dokumente. So, und ich will nicht meine Dokumente mit irgendwelchen Log-Dateien von irgendwelchen Programmen vermischt wissen.
Will ich nicht.
Das sind aber deine Personal Logs, also schon so eine Frage.
Auf jeden Fall für denjenigen, der auch schon mal über einen Clean Install nachgedacht hat, das ist definitiv etwas, was man berücksichtigen muss.
Na und es gibt noch so ein paar Programme, die es tatsächlich schaffen, das am Home-Verzeichnis als Punkt irgendwas abzuspeichern, ihre Einstellung.
Die Jürgen erschossen.
Das sind natürlich zum einen solche Sachen wie die Bash oder sowas, ganz natürliche Unix-Programme, aber... GNU-PG.
GNU-PG ist zum Beispiel.
GNU-PG, weiß ich das. Ich weiß es auf jeden Fall bei... Wie heißt denn dieser 68.000er Emulator? Basilisk, glaube ich. Der legt das da ab. Ich weiß, dass das mein heiß geliebtes Dropbox da ein unsichtbares Verzeichnis anlegt. Und... Die braucht man nicht zu ersetzen, aber ein paar Einstellungsverteilen liegen mir auch noch um bei der Gelegenheit.
Das sind meistens Programme, die so aus dem Unix-Lager kommen, die das so gewohnt sind, weil man das da halt so macht.
Ja, aber teilweise sieht man das den Programmen gar nicht so dringend an, dass die aus dem Unix-Lager kommen, sondern hat das irgendjemand vergessen.
Ne, das stimmt. Emulator sind natürlich ein gutes Beispiel, weil die natürlich quasi als User-Interface meistens...
Genau, natives User-Interface, aber die Engine unten drunter.
Genau. Naja, das muss man auf jeden Fall noch brüchseln. Bei GNU-PG ist es zum Beispiel schon etwas dramatischer, weil da liegen dann auch deine ganzen Keys, die du importiert hast. In Home, Punkt, GNU-PG. Und das kannst du halt auch mal nicht eben von so einem Backup mit Dreck und Drop im Finder rüberholen, weil natürlich normalerweise diese Verzeichnisse, die mit dem Punkt anfangen, ausgeblendet sind.
Genau. Ganz wichtig, Punkt SSH natürlich, dass man das auf jeden Fall sichert.
Genau. Das sind auch so die beiden Sachen, die ich da noch so von Hand nachtragen musste, damit das wieder alles funktioniert. Was nochmal besonders eklig war, ich hatte... Ich muss sagen, ich hab ja mit diesem Time Machine... Ich bin mir mittlerweile nicht mehr so richtig sicher, ob wir wirklich Freunde werden. Also das ist... So toll ich die Idee an sich finde mit Time Machine, so elend ist einfach die Implementierung. Wo es zum Beispiel wirklich haarig wird, ist hier mit meinen knapp 200 GB Daten, die ich auf diese Time Capsule sichere. Und wenn man das so frisch macht, dann geht das ja ganz gut. Beim ersten Mal kopiert er das mal so relativ fix weg. Und dann macht er dann immer so seine inkrementellen Updates. Wunderbar. Alles ist gut. Aber dann kommen halt so diese Fälle, wo er so mit so einem Backup schon zu 50% durch ist und dann klappst du halt den Rechner zu und verlässt das Haus. Weil du natürlich nicht immer guckst, ob gerade ein Backup läuft und was weiß ich, am Ende auch irgendwie gerade mal keine Zeit hast und irgendwie auch Stopp-Backup dauert ja ewig und auch da er dir nicht sagt, wie lange es jetzt noch dauert, verlierst du halt irgendwann die Geduld. Naja, und ich hab so den Eindruck, so häufiger man das macht, also er hat schon eine Methode wieder da aufzunehmen, wo er aufgehört hat. Was ich schon mal ziemlich bemerkenswert finde. Also, wenn er mir sagt, er hat 20 GB zu kopieren und er hat irgendwie 10 schon rüber, dann macht er beim nächsten Mal auch wirklich nur die letzten 10. Allerdings dauert es einfach ewig, bis er wieder anfängt, bis er das überhaupt weiß, was er kopieren muss. Dann dauert es ewig, dass das zu kopieren und noch schlimmer ist, es dauert nochmal ewig, bis er das dann alles abgeschlossen bekommen hat. Ich hatte jetzt seit zwei Tagen keinen Backup, weil er einfach nie zu Ende kam, weil er auch teilweise mit irgendwelchen Fehlern abgebrochen ist, wo man mir auch nicht so richtig sagt, was eigentlich jetzt hier der Fehler war. Und heute Nachmittag hat er dann das geschafft, endlich dieses Backup mal abzuschließen, das nächste Diff wohlgemerkt, kein frisches, sondern ein Diff. hat heute Nacht, also vor jetzt ungefähr 24 Stunden hab ich damit angefangen und dann hat er glaube ich 20 Stunden lang gebraucht, um das zu finishing. Also nicht die Daten zu kopieren, die waren kopiert, sondern er hat dann gesagt finishing Backup und das ging einfach ewig. Ich weiß nicht. Das ist alles irgendwie so halbseiden und es gibt einem immer nicht so richtig das Gefühl, dass alles sicher ist. Ich hatte das Problem, dass ich als ich den Rechner neu aufgesetzt hatte und dann gesagt habe, ok und jetzt bitte auch weiterhin wieder Backups machen. Da hatte ich ja so ein bisschen meine Hoffnung, dass er, ich meine ich hatte vorher da ein OS drauf, ich hab danach ein OS drauf, wusste nicht so richtig, was macht er jetzt? Macht er jetzt so einen Diff?
Na, er hält es für einen neuen Rechner, oder?
Er hat alles neu kopieren wollen. Also ich weiß nicht genau, woran das lag. Ich hab ja auch die Platte formatiert, also es war wirklich auch so richtig mit neuer Volume-ID und so weiter.
Neue iNodes und so, ne?
Aber das kam überhaupt nicht in die Hufe. Also es war einfach unmöglich, mit 200 GB, die eigentlich komplett unchanged waren, aber die er trotzdem als Diff schreiben musste, da irgendwie in die Puschen zu kommen. Also es war einfach nicht möglich, eine Woche lang davon ein Backup zu machen, per Time Machine.
Über die Time Capsule?
Über die Time Capsule. Also er kam einfach nicht zur Potter. Bis ich dann irgendwie gesagt habe, ich hab jetzt einfach keinen Bock, weiterhin kein Backup zu haben. Und hab dann meine Backup-Datei, wie Dennis von dir so schön gesagt hat, bei Time Machine dann an Disk Image, hab das halt unbenannt. Da ist ja mal die MAC-Adresse mit drin, in dem Dateinamen von dem Rechner. Hab die halt unbenannt, mit Datum, dann gab es sozusagen keinen Backup, und dann hat er eben wieder von vorne angefangen. Und dann geht das relativ fix. Also das ist irgendwie alles doof.
Also ich hab eine ganze Menge Time Machine Voodoo gemacht in den letzten Wochen, weil, also kurz Hintergrund, mein, das Display an meinem MacBook Pro war kaputt, darum musste ich das bei Graves abgeben. Wo ich übrigens mal auf deren Garantieverlängerung für 100 Euro positiv hinweisen kann. 100 Euro kostet die glaube ich vielleicht ab, oder? Die haben mir ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken, also ich hab die Original Apple Garantie von dem Jahr und jetzt noch mal zwei Jahre von Graves drauf gekauft, also auf drei Jahre verlängern lassen. Und die haben, ich hab das dahin gegeben, die haben die Sellnummer ausgelesen, wussten daraufhin meinen Namen, haben gesagt, alles klar, hier reparieren wir dir. Ich hab ein niegelnagelneues Display. Jetzt in glossy statt in matt, aber ich hab auf jeden Fall, diese 100 Euro haben sich auf jeden Fall für mich gelohnt, damals zu investieren. Das hat echt super geklappt. Ja, und für die Zeit hatte ich mir einen MacBook Air ausgeliehen. Und beim MacBook Air geht ja das erste Mal jetzt nicht mehr, was man normalerweise, wie ich normalerweise immer sowas gemacht hab, von einem Rechner auf den anderen, nämlich per karmen Copy-Kloner, das einfach rüber zu kopieren. Und darum bin ich den anderen Weg gegangen.
Weil er keinen Firewire-Wehrmacher hat und diesen Target-Diskmodus nicht hat.
Genau, weil er keinen Target-Modus hat. Also hab ich Folgendes gemacht, ich hab ein Backup gemacht auf eine USB-Platte mit Time Machine von meinem ganzen Zeug. Und hab dann auf dem MacBook Air, hab das da angeschlossen, hab gesagt, nun stellen wir mal genau diesen einen Benutzer wieder her. Aus dem Time Machine Backup von der anderen Kiste. Und das hat hervorragend geklappt. Dann hab ich das zwei Wochen lang, oder nee, zehn Tage lang etwa, die ich meinen Rechner nicht hatte, hab ich immer das Backup dann vom MacBook Air gemacht. Und gestern, als ich's wieder zurückgeholt habe, hab ich dann auf meinem MacBook Pro mein Home-Verzeichnis einfach gelöscht, das alte sozusagen, was noch drauf war, was jetzt aber nicht mehr up to date war. Und hab dann wiederum das MacBook Air Update reingespielt. Was einem anderen Punkt kleine Probleme gegeben hat, also das Festplattengehäuse hat's kurz versagt, was mich doch relativ in Panik versetzt hatte.
Was hat versagt?
Das Festplattengehäuse, das Externe von meiner USB-Festplatte. Und ich dachte schon, die Platte wär im Arsch. Und ich hatte mich dämlicherweise in der Situation gebracht, dass das die einzige Kopie meines Home-Verzeichnisses war. Das heißt, ich hätte genauso neu angefangen wie du im Zweifelsfall. Das hat sich dann aber als... Also ich hab dann ein anderes Gehäuse draufgepackt, dann war alles super. Kurzer Schockmoment, aber ansonsten hat das hervorragend geklappt mit diesem Hin- und Herkopieren von diesen diversen Backups aus allen möglichen Quellen. Und ich hab jetzt auf dieser einen USB-Festplatte von drei verschiedenen Rechner Backups drauf. Läuft wieder eins.
Ich glaub, dass das Time-Machine ganz gut funktioniert auf Platten. Auf lokalen Platten, mein ich.
Ich mach's nur auf lokalen Platten.
Ja, da ist das irgendwie schnell genug.
Das ist schnell genug. Also ich kenn das auch mit diesem Backup abschließend.
Aber über das Netz ist das irgendwie... Ich weiß nicht. Das dauert einfach zu lange. Also ich glaub, der leidet auch sehr unter der Latenz. Der braucht gerade für diese Diff-Bildung, braucht der einfach... Ja, weil das halt einfach, ne, warten auf das Ergebnis und so weiter und das schaukelt sich so auf und deswegen dauert das dann eben auch so furchtbar lange. Ich hatte dann noch so ein anderes Problem, dass ich halt in dem anderen Backup, in dem alten Sachen dann nochmal so hier und da mal rausziehen wollte, nochmal hier eine Präftdatei und so weiter, die irgendwie woanders noch rumlag. Allerdings hatte mein neuer User eine andere User-ID als mein alter User.
Sodass du nicht mehr die Rechte hattest?
Ja, dann hatte ich diese Rechte nicht mehr und konnte da auch nicht drauf zugreifen, weil ich natürlich im User-Kontext drauf zugreife. Auch da, so usability-technisch, war das so ein bisschen schwierig. Gut, da muss ich dann halt in meinen Backup gehen und dann irgendwie die Permissions ändern, aber man will ja eigentlich auch...
Eigentlich sollte man sowas nicht anfassen müssen.
Ja, man will ja auch gerade in seinem Backup nicht... Ja, das ist alles nicht so schön.
Ich hab bei meinem Rechen auch ein neuer installiert.
Hast du eigentlich Bitthorn laufen? Ein bisschen? Ja, es gibt hier Klagen im Chat.
So wird das nichts mit dem... Ich hab jedenfalls meinen Rechen auch neu installiert. Weil ich mir eine 500 GB Platte für meinen Laptop gegönnt habe. Und da muss man...
Die gleiche, die ich auch habe, wenn ich das richtig sage.
Und...
Dieser superschnelle...
Mit anderen Worten, ich hab ganz versehentlich was super Tolles gekauft.
Wie schnell war die?
73 Megabyte die Sekunde.
73 Megabyte, so eine Read.
Ja und ich hab das jetzt hier so mit... Ich hab ne Datei, was hab ich gemacht? Ich glaub, ich hab in nem MD5 auf irgendeiner Lost-Folge gemacht, die riesengroß ist. Ich hab hier irgendwie so Blu-Ray-Lost-Folgen, voll toll. Und jedenfalls... Hatte die mit 73 Megabyte die Sekunde eingelesen. Also schwank natürlich auch ab und zu. Man kommt auch an, wie fragmentiert das ist, wo die Daten liegen. Aber so grundsätzlich, das ist das, was die Platte schaffen kann.
Was ist das für eine Platte?
Eine Western Digital Scorpio Blue. Die gibt's irgendwie auch in Scorpio Black. Die Black sind wohl irgendwie richtig doll, schnell, so richtig teuer. Aber die gibt's wohl nicht in 500 Gigabyte. Und die Blue gibt's in 500 Gigabyte. Die ist, weiß nicht, vor einem Monat oder zwei rausgekommen und ist so eine richtig günstige 500 Gigabyte Platte, weil vorher waren die relativ teuer oder hatten die falsche Bau oder hatten die noch 12 Millimeter. Jetzt ist die mit 9,5, passt rein und kostet irgendwie 95 Euro oder so.
Und die dreht mit 7,2?
Ne, mit 5,4.
Echt, mit 5,4 und die ist so schnell?
Ja, weil die halt 500 Gigabyte hat, ist die Datendichte bei dir so hoch, dass du halt Probenregungen so viel einliest und du willst auch gar keine Platte im Laptop mit 7,2.
Da will man aber wirklich ZFS drauf haben, oder?
Hab ich nicht.
Ja, aber man will es haben.
Ich will das überall haben.
Also, um da nochmal kurz zurückzukommen, bei dem Talk ist mir das irgendwie nochmal so richtig aufgegangen. Also gerade diese Berichte von, da waren ja auch diverse Leute, die das so in der Praxis auch so hatten, diese Fehlerraten, die Platten so haben. Also wie häufig die mal falsche Daten liefern, die ist echt scary. Ich wundere mich ja ehrlich gesagt, warum mein Computer überhaupt funktioniert. Oder andererseits, ich wundere mich nicht mehr so sehr, wenn er mal nicht funktioniert.
Also zum Beispiel, es gibt diese kleinen USB-Schnuffis, die kosten 7 Euro bei Ebay. Das ist ein USB-Kabel mit einem Plastikgehäuse, wo IDE dranpasst und IDE für 2,5 Zoll und ein SATA-Stecker, dass du IDE-Platten oder SATA-Platten dran machen kannst. Genau, die heißen wirklich Tri-Fu. Da hab ich letztens auch mal eine ZFS drauf gemacht und hab was drauf geschoben. Der meldet da schon andauernd Eros. Dieses Tri-Fu ist halt auch so eine billig Hongkong-China-Scheiße. Das ist einfach billig. Da kommen einfach lauter Fehler. Man sollte auch seinen Backup nicht über so ein Tri-Fu schicken. Das ZFS merkt das halt gnadenlos. Am Anfang war in den ZFS-Foren immer, ich hab jetzt hier ZFS, aber es hat ja irgendwie nur Fehler. Das wär voll der Scheiß. Aber es hat halt Fehler, weil das ZFS es halt gemerkt hat. Vorher haben sie es halt nie gemerkt. Die Fehler waren schon immer da. Genauso mit kaputter Hardware. Die merkst du mit ZFS halt sofort, weil das ZFS zickt dann sofort rum.
Das war wirklich der erhellende Teil des Vortragabends, muss ich sagen. Ich wusste das war schon irgendwie alles vorher, aber das war ja auch so massiv da bei den ganzen Berichten, die dann kamen.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich am ZFS irgendwie eigentlich unbedingt haben will, warum ich es so toll finde, dass es halt Check-Something hat und diese Silent Errors sind einfach damit nicht mehr, die gibt es einfach nicht mehr im ZFS.
Ja, man weiß einfach, dass die Daten, wie sie mal geschrieben wurden, auch tatsächlich zurückkommen.
Genau, man hat ein gutes Gefühl. Wenn du eine Platte nach zwei Jahren irgendwie aus der Schublade holst mit einem ZFS, da machst du da so einen Scrub drüber, der checkt einmal alles durch, was irgendwie belegt ist und sagt dir, ist okay, oder sagt dir, ist nicht okay, und kann dir genau sagen, die Datei, die hat halt irgendwie eine Macke und dann weiß es halt wenigstens. Aber so irgendwie ist die Datei ein Stück kaputt und du hast irgendwie keine Ahnung und dann willst du irgendwann mal loslegen und die benutzen und nichts geht.
Das Passwort geht doch nicht.
Genau.
Gerade bei Krypto, ich meine, bei nicht verschlüsselten Dateisystemen, dann mag das ja noch irgendwie, ja, dann kippt da, was weiß ich, ein paar Bits in so einem JPEG um oder so.
Ja, wenn es mal ein JPEG ist, kann da auch was anderes sein.
Klar.
Wenn es deinen Programmcode erwischt.
Ja, es muss dich aber nicht gleich voll hart treffen, aber bei Krypto trifft es dich dann eigentlich auch gleich hart. Weil dann passt halt unter Umständen einfach gar nichts mehr zusammen. Also das... Tja, wie hast du denn deinen Fresh Install jetzt gemacht?
Na, ich hab die neue Platte eingebaut. Also ich hab die nicht mal vorher getestet. Ich dachte, ich mach jetzt mal so ein Speed-Update. Bin halt zum Händler gefahren, hab die Platte geholt, bin wieder nach Hause gedüst, hab mir gleich noch 4 GB dazu geschoppt und deswegen hab ich gedacht, mach ich das alles gleich in einem Abwasch. Also Rechner auseinandergeschraubt, 23 Schrauben sind es bei dem alten MacBook Pro. Platte eingebaut, alte rausgenommen, alles wieder zugeschraubt. Die alte Platte, die ich vorher drin hatte, halt an so ein Trifo gescheckt, weil das Ding halt SATA hat und ich hatte sonst nichts, wo ich SATA dranhängen kann. Dann hab ich irgendwie das, mein Mac neu installiert, auf die 500 GB Platte halt, frisch. Und dann sagt der dann hier, willst du irgendwie deine Daten von so einem anderen Volume irgendwie retten. Dann hab ich die Platte da angeschlossen, hab gesagt, ja, hätte ich gerne. Und zwar die User-Daten von hier Dennis und irgendwie vom System nix außer die Netzwerkeinstellung. Rest soll er irgendwie in Ruhe lassen. Und ich hab ja FileVault, ich hab schon mal gucken, ob das mal hinhaut. Aber er hat mir den User angelegt, mit dem Passport irgendwie. Ich hab das, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich zu dem Zeitpunkt schon eins eingestellt hatte, wo ich dann das Gleiche genommen hab, wenn ich's gemacht hab, oder noch gar nicht so weit war, dass es automatisch funktioniert hat. Jedenfalls hat das Filevolt irgendwie so 3-4 GB hab ich da, hat da rüberkopiert und hat gebootet und 1A wie vorher. Ich brauchte nur noch, ich hab halt eine extra Partition für meine Daten. Und die hab ich von Hand kopiert.
Dieser, wie heißt das Ding noch gleich? Dieser Migration Assistant, der funktioniert an sich ganz, ganz gut.
Rock'n'Roll. Also ich hab vom Händler bis irgendwie die Kiste wieder lief, 2 Stunden oder so.
Wenn ich das gemacht hätte, hätt ich aber wahrscheinlich den gleichen Scheiß wie vorher. Und das wollt ich ja verhindern.
Aber in meinem Home, also meine Preferenz habe ich eigentlich keinen Scheiß. Das sind mehr so die Programme, die ja in User, Local, Zeug, irgendwie über rumkacken.
Ja, aber ich hatte so viele Merkwürdigkeiten. Also es haben einfach bestimmte Dinge nicht mehr funktioniert. Also was weiß ich, iTunes war nie in der Lage, das Passwort vom iTunes-Account aus der Keychain zu holen oder da abzulegen.
Das war, weil du irgendwann mal mit deinen...
Das hab ich bei iTunes nie gemacht. Du meinst diese Service-Krabber-Geschichte, wo man irgendwie Sprachen entfernen konnte, um Platz zu sparen oder sowas. Ja, das hab ich da aber nie gemacht. Und es gab einfach eine Fülle an Merkwürdigkeiten. Oder was weiß ich, wenn ich zwischen Safari und Textmade hin und her geschaltet habe, dann dauerte einfach dieser Kontext-Switch auf Textmade einfach fünf Sekunden. Warum? Auch immer. Gab dafür keine gute Erklärung.
Wann ist dein System?
Jetzt ist das alles weg.
Das kommt ja natürlich auch wieder irgendwann.
Das steht zu befürchten, aber wenn es jetzt erst mal nur zwei Jahre dauert, dann kann ich zumindest schon mal wieder zwei Jahre aufbauen. Aber das kostet bei mir richtig Zeit. Weil das ist so das, was ich, wenn ich so einen Podcast abhöre, dann bin ich die ganze Zeit zum Texteditor.
Ich hab ja auch nur Standardprogramme, aber ich war relativ schnell wieder oben. Und natürlich mit der Zeit muss man immer wieder hier installieren und da installieren. Vorhin hab ich auch gemerkt, dass mein ZFS, ich hab jetzt wieder die Read-Only-Version und muss jetzt wieder auf diese 119 da irgendwie mal aufspringen. Aber ich benutze ZFS auf dem Mac gar nicht so viel, weil es einfach noch nicht wirklich benutzbar.
Tja, wir wollen das haben. Unbedingt.
Was ich noch kurz erwähnen wollte, weil ich werde ja auch im Twitter so oft gefragt, irgendwie wie das nun aussieht mit ZFS und wie man es machen sollte und Backup und Zeug. Auch wenn ich viel von ZFS rede und auch auf dem Mac das genau beobachte, empfehlen würde ich das auf dem Mac noch nicht?
Das kann man auch nicht.
Also wenn da Leute irgendwie vorhaben, da sich irgendwie so eine Kiste zu basteln mit ZFS als Backup oder so. Also ich glaube schon, dass das ZFS an sich stabil ist und die Daten nicht verloren gehen. Aber trotzdem hat der Mac halt mir noch zu oft Kernel-Penis, wenn man irgendwie vergisst, das von Hand irgendwie zu ejecten und so. Und wenn man nicht der absolute bastelt, würde ich erstmal noch die Finger davon lassen.
So, soll ich mal ein paar?
Ja Max, du hast was Neues.
Ich hab hier so ein kleines Spielzeug in der Hand. Und zwar das...
Das soll ein typisches Geräusch sein?
Das ist leider ein typisches Geräusch. Es geht hier um das berühmte G1 mit Google. Ich glaube, er heißt offiziell T-Mobile G1 with Google. Womit wir schonmal an einem Schwachpunkt wären.
Du hast da ein Google drin.
Nee, der Name ist einfach... Denkt euch mal was besseres aus dafür. Die Telekom hat mir eins zugeschickt zum Testen, damit wir da drüber ein bisschen berichten. Will ich jetzt noch gar nicht so ausführlich machen, weil ich hab's jetzt erst seit zwei Tagen. Ich hab's mir schon sehr genau angeguckt, aber noch nicht genau genug, um mir wirklich einen abschließenden Eindruck zu machen. Aber so einen ersten Einblick kann man ja schon mal bieten. Du hast aber kräftig geflucht. Ich hab am Anfang kräftig geflucht. Ich war am Anfang geradezu entsetzt. Das hat sich mittlerweile deutlich gebessert.
Da ist ja jetzt hier so ein Android drauf, oder?
Da ist Android drauf.
Gibt's eigentlich auch schon Versionen? Android gibt's ja schon eine Weile länger.
Ja, da gibt's Versionen, aber ich weiß nicht, wer hier das ist, um ehrlich zu sein. Ich hab noch nicht rausgekriegt, wo das steht. Wahrscheinlich irgendwo in den Einstellungen. Und da soll demnächst auch mal eine neue Version draus kommen. Also natürlich entwickeln die das tapfer weiter. Was erstmal ganz schick ist, also man schaltet das, man bekommt dieses Android, dieses G1. Was so ein bisschen, also es sieht, schön ist es nicht. Das ist so ein schwarzes Ding, mit abgerundeten Ecken, sie haben sich nicht mal wirklich Mühe gegeben.
Das ist einen halben Zentimeter höher als... als ein iPhone. Ist ein bisschen schmaler, aber nur ganz minimal. Und ist aber...
Deutlich dicker.
Ja, deutlich ist es schon noch mal die Hälfte dicker oder so. Hat dafür aber eine Tastatur.
Hat dafür eine Tastatur. Also man schaltet das Ding einmal ein. Und dann kommt eine Abfrage. Hallo, willkommen bei Android sozusagen. Dann kriegt man erstmal so erklärt, wie man mit den Fingern auf einem Display rumditscht und so was. Das ist eine kleine Anführung. Und dann kriegt man erklärt, wie man dieses Display aufschiebt, um an die Tastatur ranzukommen. Und dann gibt man da seine Gmail-Adresse ein und sein Passwort. Und dann sagt er, bitte warten Sie ein paar Minuten. Und man kann aber schon anfangen. Und während man unterwegs ist auf seinem Telefon, werden alle Kontakte, also die ganzen E-Mail-Sachen, alle Google-Talk-Sachen, also alles, was irgendwie von Google stammt, und wird im Hintergrund runtergeladen, ist dann auf dem Gerät verfügbar. Also man hat sofort seinen Kalender, man hat sofort sein Adressbuch. Das ist wirklich eine schöne Sache. Und wenn ich das aktualisiere, entweder auf dem Gerät oder auf dem Desktop, dann wird das auch relativ schnell jeweils übertragen, entweder vom Telefon auf den Desktop oder umgekehrt. Also das, was man beim iPhone mit Mobile Me relativ teuer dazu kaufen muss, ist beim G1 dabei. Und funktioniert.
Welches Software musst du dazu auf dem Mac zum Einsatz bringen?
Absolut gar keine, weil er synchronisiert es nicht mit deinem Adressbuch, sondern nur mit dem Google-Adressbuch. Also deinem Gmail-Adressbuch.
Also er macht nur Overseer?
Er macht komplett alles Overseer. Also es gibt eigentlich keinen, außer wenn man Musik draufbringen will vielleicht, gibt es keinen Grund, das Gerät per USB anzuschließen. Es läuft komplett alles Overseer. Das Gerät hat so einen kleinen App-Store beim iPhone, das ist der Market heißt das Ding, wo man sich zusätzliche Programme runterladen kann. Die Programmqualität reicht von ziemlich gut bis totaler Scheiße. Also ich hab einige Programme erlebt, ein Screenshot-Programm, was genau diese eine Funktion nicht beherrscht, ein Screenshot zu machen.
Wo ist denn dieses Ding? Ich find das ja gerade nicht. Achso, das ist mit diesen mehreren User-Interface-Ebenen, ne?
Ja, da gewöhnt man sich dran.
Da gewöhnt man sich dran?
Da gewöhnt man sich dran.
Ich probier das jetzt schon das dritte Mal.
Also man kann das... Also es gibt so ein Menü, es gibt so ein Start-Screen, dass man, ähnlich wie beim iPhone, was man sich komplett einrichten kann, wie man mag. Also da kann man Alkons draufschmeißen und kann eine Uhr hinpacken und hat so verschiedene Widgets und es werden bestimmt schnell deutlich mehr Widgets werden. Da legt man auch die... Dann hat man noch so ein Pop-Up-Menü unten, wo alle Programme drin sind. Und da kann man dann per Drag-and-Drop relativ schön die Sachen nehmen und auf seinen Desktop fallen lassen. Das ist eine übersichtliche Sache, also das ist definitiv besser als beim Springboard.
Worüber hast du denn geflucht?
Worüber ich geflucht habe, ist erstmal über die Akkulaufzeit. Also die erste Akkuladung habe ich tatsächlich in, ich würde sagen, nicht mal 6 Stunden leer bekommen.
Das ist ja rumgespielt wie ein Blöder.
Da habe ich eine Menge rumgespielt, dann habe ich den Akku voll geladen und dann bin ich abends unterwegs gewesen und habe nicht so wahnsinnig viel rumgespielt und es war wieder nach ungefähr 6 Stunden leer. Was jetzt allerdings sich deutlich gebessert hat, seitdem ich... Ich habe sofort so ein Twitter-Klient installiert, weil wofür will man dieses G1 haben? Was ist der Unterschied zum iPhone? Es kann Programm im Hintergrund laufen und es gibt natürlich ohne Ende Twitter-Klients, die die Tweets auch im Hintergrund nachladen. Und dieses Programm hat offensichtlich Akku gesaugt ohne Ende. Seitdem ich das Programm...
Hintergrundprogramme.
Seitdem ich das beendet habe, hält der Akku deutlich länger. Ist jetzt immer noch nicht auf iPhone-Niveau. Und das iPhone hält ja nun wirklich nicht sonderlich lange durch. Aber jetzt kommt man über den Tag, sage ich mal. Aber dazu kann ich wahrscheinlich auch erst nach 2 Wochen so richtig viel sagen. Worüber ich auch geflucht habe, ist der Web-Browser leider. Also Android hat, genauso wie das iPhone, ein komplettes Web-Kit hinten drinnen. Also diese gleiche Engine, die auch bei Safari drin ist. Die auch bei Chrome drin ist. Die eigentlich mittlerweile fast überall dabei ist, außer bei Microsoft Windows, wenn man es mal so fast zusammenfassend sagen kann. Und bei Opera. Na ja, es gibt noch Firefox, aber als Default-Installation sozusagen.
Ja, richtig.
Und man startet diesen Browser und er ruft erstmal Google auf. Und wenn man da eine URL eingeben muss, muss man erstmal auf die Menütaste drücken, muss dann URL eingeben auswählen, dann geht ein URL-Feld auf, dann muss man dieses Schiebedisplay hochschieben, muss an die Tastatur ran, muss URL eingeben und return drücken. Das klingt jetzt nicht nach sonderlich viel, aber es ist, man muss sich, also beim iPhone, egal was es ist, man kommt auf dieses Display und man sieht die Option, die man einfach hat. Man muss nicht in irgendwelchen Menüstrukturen rumsuchen oder sowas, man tippt in die Adresseleiste rein und kann anfangen zu tippen. Und bei diesem G1 ist das, das sind immer so Denkprozesse. Man gewöhnt sich da bestimmt dran, man hat das bestimmt irgendwann mal relativ intuitiv drauf, aber so gerade am Anfang ist man auch ziemlich am Rumsuchen überall. Und dann, was ich wirklich traurig finde, sind in diesen Browsern ein paar Einstellungs-Sachen, also zum Beispiel das iPhone. Wenn man auf eine Seite draufkommt, dann zeigt das ja einem erst mal die Seite komplett verkleinert an, also dass man so einen Überblick über die Seite hat. Und das macht das G1 nicht, sondern es zeigt quasi auf 100% die Seite an, dass man bei den meisten Seiten einfach nicht viel mehr sieht, als direkt die Headline oben. Du kannst jetzt leider nicht ins Bein, ich hab jetzt einen Airplane-Modus eingeschrieben, damit ich nicht Interferenzen hatte. Wieso ist das?
Das ist auf 3G, oder?
Das ist 3G, aber wir haben es vorhin wirklich laut in der Technik, in den Mikros rumlaufen hören. Und ist dann im 100%-Modus drinne quasi. Und dann kann man erst mal anfangen, rauszuzoomen, um die Seite sehen zu können, und dann kann man wieder anfangen, reinzuzoomen. Es gibt auch nicht so schöne Sachen wie Doppeltipp auf eine Textspalte, damit das dann ranzoomt oder sowas. Also dieses wirklich intuitive Surfen beim iPhone, das kann das Gerät schlicht und ergreifend noch nicht. Das funktioniert erstaunlich viel im Web. Also es funktioniert genauso viel wie in Safari auch. Eigentlich jede Seite ist irgendwie verfügbar, die ich so gesehen habe. Gibt keine Probleme.
Mal gucken, ob ich in der Lage bin, es auf WLAN umzustellen. Siehst du, genau das war der Grund. Kann ich im Airplane-Modus...
WLAN einschalten? Nein, das habe ich schon probiert.
Echt? Aha, was macht man dann im Airplane, wo es WLAN gibt?
Wahrscheinlich sich keine Airplane-Modus einschalten.
Sich eine Third-Party-Applikation runterladen, die in der Lage ist, WLAN einzuschalten, obwohl der Airplane-Modus alles... Also das ist wirklich, das ist nicht der...
Mal gucken, ob ich überhaupt in der Lage bin, hier WLAN zuzuschalten. Das ist immer so ein Usability-Test. Das wird jetzt, glaube ich, nichts hier. Wieso ist denn das nicht in... Du bist doch OpaO2.
Nee, das ist jetzt eine T-Mobile-Karte, die auch gerade ist.
Hab ich hier so schlechten T-Mobile-Empfang?
Ja, bei mir in der Wohnung übrigens genauso. Da ist mein O2-Empfang auch deutlich besser als T-Mobile-Empfang. Naja, auf jeden Fall, das ist alles noch nicht so ganz das wahre. Es ist natürlich alles um Meilen besser, als man es von Windows Mobile kennt und von Symbian oder von wem auch immer. Wenn man es aber direkt mit dem iPhone vergleicht, dann ist, was die Usability angeht, dass G1 doch in vielen Punkten deutlich unterlegen. Aber nicht in allen. Also es gibt zum Beispiel, was ist, was zum Beispiel der Fall ist, wenn man bei Qwaipe, was ich auf dem iPhone ganz furchtbar finde, ich nutze ziemlich gerne Qwaipe, lasse mir irgendwelche Kneipe in der Gegend anzeigen, dann lasse ich mir auf der Karte anzeigen, wo ist die denn, diese Kneipe? Und dann bin ich in einer Karte drin, also klicke ich auf die Adresse, lasse mir das in der Karte anzeigen.
Ah, das ist furchtbar.
Und dann bin ich in der Karte drin und komme nicht wieder zurück nach Qwaipe, weil dann muss ich wieder beenden über Springboard. Und das geht hier einfach über diesen Back-Button. Der Back-Button funktioniert aber leider auch nicht ganz so intuitiv, wie man sich das vorstellt.
Für sowas muss man ja anderes machen, außer ihn drücken.
Na ja, er macht nicht immer das, was man erwartet. In einigen Applikationen ist er quasi wie ein Back-Button im Browser. Inklusive in diesem Market, dass er einem nachdem man was installiert hat, noch mal den Installationsdialog anzeigt, den man dann auch per Back-Button zurückkommt. Im Kalender beendet er einfach den Kalender. Keine Ahnung warum. Wenn man von der Monatsansicht auf die Tagesansicht umschaltet, was man ja relativ häufig macht, und dann wieder zurück will auf Monatsansicht, funktioniert der Back-Button nicht. Da sind viele Sachen noch sehr inkonsistent. Was großartig ist, wo es sich mal lohnt mit dem ganzen im Hintergrund Zeug, ist die Push-Mail-Funktion und Google Talk. Also diese Chat-Funktion. Das macht wirklich Laune. Man startet im Instant Messenger, sieht fast wie auf dem Desktop seine ganzen Kontakte, tippt einen an, fängt an eine Nachricht zu schreiben und dann sendet man die ab. Man kann mit mehreren Leuten gleichzeitig chatten. Das funktioniert ziemlich großartig.
Mir ist es ja immer noch ein Rätsel, warum Apple da beim Chatting noch keine Lösung gefunden hat.
Das wundert mich auch ein bisschen.
Aber am Ende hat es mit damit zu tun, was du eben schon selber bemerkt hast. Hintergrund-Applikationen saugen Strom und Stromsaugen ist keine gute Idee.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, jetzt habe ich ja dieses Push-Mail auch an und jetzt hält der Akku ja OK. Also jedenfalls deutlich besser als vorher. Ja, also das ist so bisher. WLAN hast du geschafft.
Sehr gut.
WLAN habe ich geschafft. Das ist schon mal besser als das Nokia. Da habe ich mir meinen Spaß draus gemacht und das irgendwelchen Leuten in die Hand gegeben. Hab gesagt, versuch mal in dein eigenes WLAN reinzukommen. Vor allem von mir hat das gemacht. Der sozusagen voll Besitzer einer geistigen Kräfte und vor allem auch der Kenntnis über die Zugangsdaten zu seinem WLAN verfügte. Und ich hab ihm halt meinen Nokia E61 gegeben, hab gesagt, so, jetzt buche dich mal ein. Versuch mal deinen WLAN zu betreten. Was man so lange gebraucht hat, habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt.
Nee, ich glaube nicht, aber das funktioniert so irgendwie. Muss man einen Webbrowser starten oder eine Applikation starten?
Ich kann es dir nicht erklären. Ich habe es bisher jedes Mal wieder vergessen. Es ist irgendwas mit so neuen Ebenenmenüs, die irgendwie heißen, Settings, Configurations, you name it, irgendeinen Scheiß oder Profiles. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich konnte es ihm auch nicht sagen. Ich habe ihm nur dieses Ding gegeben und gesagt, du bist seit 20 Jahren Computer Nerd, find es raus. 17 Minuten hat er gedauert. 17 Minuten braucht er.
Das WLAN-Modul, da habe ich bisher noch gemischte Gefühle. Zunächst funktioniert das auf dem iPhone. Wenn man einmal im WLAN drin war, verbindet er sich automatisch wieder mit diesem WLAN. Das ist ja wirklich instant. Man kommt rein in die Wohnung, holt das Ding raus, lädt sich irgendwas per App Store runter und man ist im WLAN. Am Anfang hat das auf dem G1 überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Da habe ich stundenlang mich in Reichweite eines WLANs aufgehalten, ohne dass er mir irgendwas angezeigt hätte. Mittlerweile funktioniert das relativ. Am zweiten Tag hat es dann erstaunlicherweise funktioniert, dass er sich auch halbwegs automatisch irgendwo in WLAN eingehängt hat, dass er sich automatisch verbindet mit dem WLAN. Und auch, dass er einem sehr viel angenehm unauffälliger als beim iPhone anzeigt, wenn er, ich habe übrigens WLAN Netze gefunden, will es sich mit einem verbinden. Und zwar zeigt er das hier oben über diese, das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie die Benülleiste auf dem Mac oder sowas. Die kann man so runterfahren. Und da erscheinen so alle Notifications, was im Hintergrund passiert ist.
Also das Herunterfahren war jetzt so eine Geste oben rein. Also das, das muss ich sagen, finde ich ja an diesem ganzen Android User Interface wirklich furchtbar. Also diese, diese zahlreichen versteckten Sachen, die man irgendwo rausziehen kann. Und du hast wie sowas menüartiges auf deinem Desktop. Dann hast du noch mal diese komische Pfeil, diesen Pfeillappen, der da irgendwie immer in deinen Bildschirm rein ragt. Ja, for no reason. Dann kannst du da drin auch nochmal rumscrollen und dann kannst du oben deine Menüzahlen auch nochmal runterziehen. Also das ist...
Also diese notification area da oben, die finde ich super. Die ist... Also wie gesagt, man sieht für alles, es erscheint ein Alken, für alles, was so passiert ist. Also wenn eine neue Mail da ist, dann sieht man das. Wenn man eine Chat-Nachricht bekommt, dann steht da auch der Text der Chat-Nachricht, sodass man das kurz unauffällig lesen kann. Wenn neue WLAN-Netze gefunden worden sind, dann erscheinen die da auch. Und dann geht man dann runter, holt sich das runter, wenn man soweit ist. Und diese Benachrichtigung. Und dann kann man draufklicken, nicht so wie beim iPhone, was ja hin und wieder schon mal sehr, sehr nervig ist. Du bist irgendwo auf der Straße unterwegs oder so. Oder in der S-Bahn und tippst irgendwie eine SMS und plötzlich kommt mittendrin so eine Hallo, möchtest du dich mit diesem WLAN verbinden, was ich irgendwie mal für dreieinhalb Sekunden gerade gesehen habe, was ich schon sehr, sehr verständigt.
Das geht einem die ganze Zeit vor die Nase. Das mit den Notifications ist definitiv Verbesserungswürdig. Haben wir ja auch schon festgestellt, als wir bei den Prih geredet haben, die ja auch einen ganz interessanten Ansatz haben.
Und gerade, wenn so viele Sachen im Hintergrund laufen, ist das ganz schön. Der MP3-Player z.B. blendet da so ein kleines Play-Icon ein. Und wenn man auf das Play-Icon drauf tippt, dann kommt man in die Steuerung zum MP3-Player und man kann ihn steuern. Da sind schon ein paar schöne Sachen dabei.
Okay, nifty Features.
Genau.
Bin ich ja mal gespannt, wie das so ausgeht. Wie lange wirst du damit jetzt noch rumspielen können?
Also, ich hab rausgehandelt, dass ich das noch bis zur nächsten Sendung haben darf. Also mit anderen Worten...
Zwei Wochen.
Zwei Wochen. Stellt mir bitte Fragen. Dann würd ich nämlich nächste Woche vielleicht beim nächsten Mal noch ein bisschen mehr erzählen.
Genau, in die Kommentare.
Genau, in die Kommentare rein. Und am besten jetzt nicht so was wie welche Linux-Könne-Version arbeitet da, weil das weiß ich gar nicht, sondern was so im Alltag ist. Ich glaube, so einen Alltagsbericht kann ich einen ganz guten dann abliefern.
Na Dennis, dich interessiert das G1 überhaupt nicht, wa?
Ich hab ein iPhone.
Das kam aber wie aus der Pistole geschossen jetzt. Dann interessiert dich aber vielleicht Maxens zweites Gadget.
Genau.
Das hab ich mir ja vorhin schon zeigen lassen. Aber hat doch gleich einen Colonel Panic gehabt.
Ich hab mir nämlich, weil ich nicht wusste, wie gesagt, als ich meinen Rechner in Reparatur gegeben habe, was würde denn jetzt passieren, wusste ich nicht, ob ich mir einen Mac irgendwo ausleihen kann, dann hab ich mir von Johnny, von Spreeblick so ein nette Puck gebockt, so ein MSI Wind. Und da war vorher ein Windows drauf, dann hab ich erst mal ein Linux drauf gepackt und bin...
MSI Wind, das heißt MS Wind.
Wind, MSI Wind. U100, um ganz genau zu sein.
MSI ist was für eine Bude?
Keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, das ist irgendein...
Touchy Mint, Flower Power, Enterprises, Taiwan Deluxe.
Irgendwie sowas, die sich jetzt wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal Speicherchips oder weißt du was drauf geliefert haben und jetzt so ein bisschen auf den Markt wagen. Die haben auch nicht viele Netbooks auf ihrer Webseite, also gibt es einen U90 und einen U100 und ich weiß auch nicht wo genau die sich alle unterscheiden. Das U100 war relativ populär in Deutschland oder ist nach wie vor. Gab es nämlich eine Zeit lang auch bei Aldi unter dem Namen Medion Icona, glaube ich.
Was ist denn jetzt an dem, was du hast, so interessant?
Das ist ein kleiner Rechner, hat eine 80 GB Festplatte, mittlerweile ein 160er, die verkauft werden, kostet so etwas mehr als 300 Euro. Hat eine für ein Netbook ordentliche Tastatur. Also die sind zwar etwas kleiner als bei einem normalen Laptop, die Tasten, aber da kann man vernünftig drauf tippen. Hat ein okayes 1024 x 600 Pixel Display. Und es hat sich in Hackintosh-Kreisen herumgesprochen, dass wohl die Hardware relativ gut geeignet sei, um darauf einen Mac OS X zu installieren.
Was du dann auch getan hast.
Was ich dann auch getan habe. Und nachdem ich beim letzten Mal irgendwie im Nachtrag erzählt habe, dass ich daran komplett gescheitert wäre, kam dann über den Chat der Hinweis, dass ich es doch mal mit IPC OS X versuchen sollte. Was ich dann auch gemacht habe. Was man im Torrent seines Vertrauens bekommt. Womit man natürlich gegen...
Jetzt kannst du mal wieder deinen Airplane-Modus einschalten. Jetzt haben wir genug geredet.
Aber man hat auch das Gefühl, dass es einen Zacken lauter ist als... Also ich hab... So, jetzt wird er, wenn er in Flugmodus geht, sich noch einmal kurz ganz laut beschweren. Wahrscheinlich um der Welt zu sagen, dass er gleich weg ist. Genau, dann hab ich mir diese ISO runtergeladen, hab das auf eine DVD gebrannt.
Warte mal, was für eine ISO hast du dir runtergeladen?
Jetzt muss ich dir einen ganz genauen Namen raussuchen.
Das heißt, man raubt sich da ein komplettes OS X oder was?
So ein 10.56.
Nee, man hat es ja schon.
Also ich hab ja eins gehabt und hatte darum nicht mal ein schlechtes Gewissen. Man verstößt natürlich gegen die Lizenzbestimmung von Apple.
Gibt es eigentlich keine Mate heute?
Doch, die liegt auch schon im Kühlschrank für dich. Hast du hier keine rausgenommen? Tja, dann musst du ja mal eine holen.
Brückst du deine mit?
Du weißt ja, wo das ist.
Ich bin mal kurz weg und mach keinen Scheiß.
Genau, ich lass mir noch mal kurz hier das MSI Wind erzählen. Ups, Rumpel, Rumpel, Rumpel, das musst du alles wieder rausschneiden.
Und ja, dann hab ich das davon hochgefahren, dann kommt man erst mal nach ein bisschen rumprobieren in den ganz normalen...
Was ist jetzt auf diesem ISO?
Da ist eine normale Mac OS X, also eine relativ normale Mac OS X Installation drauf.
Also die vertreiben das sozusagen schon so mit komplett gerobb, Warta OS X. Ist jetzt nicht nur so etwas, was man bootet und dann nimmt man seine Original-CD dazu.
Nee, das gibt's auch. Also es gibt auch so eine Lösung, die hab ich nicht ausprobiert. Die Lösung, die ich jetzt probiert habe, ist ein komplettes Mac OS X. Und mit dem normalen Installer, der aber erweitert ist, um massenhaft Optionen von wegen, welche Patches will man dazu haben, welche Kernel-Versionen will man haben, welche Tastatur-Treiber, Grafikkartentreiber etc. Das heißt, man muss die Hardware von dem Rechner, auf dem man es installieren will, schon sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr gut kennen.
Das ist halt so Original-PC-Feeling.
Das ist schon noch einen Zacken schlimmer als Original-PC. Ja, aber es findet auch keinerlei Erkennung in irgendeiner Form statt. Ich hab's das erste Mal geschafft, als ich es installiert hatte, hatte ich keine Tastatur, es führ zwar hoch, ich hatte das Display nach völlig falschen Auflösungen. Das schaltete komplett, dann hab ich mir irgendwo in einem Forum zusammengesucht, was installiert man denn auf so einem Wind? Da stand sehr, sehr exakt, welche Checkbox man wo anklicken muss. Und das hab ich dann getan.
Das Ding ist aber nicht leichter als ein R, oder?
Das ist nicht leichter als ein R. Kostet aber ein Fünftel von einem R.
Ein Fünftel?
Das kostet, wie gesagt, 300 Euro so knapp. Ich hab hier gerade irgendwo gelesen, dass man das R auch zu teuer. Das R kann man auch als Medium, als B, für 250 Euro bekommen. Dann hab ich das erfolgreich installiert. Dann muss ich noch einen Grafikkartentreiber dazu installieren, damit er dann auch wirklich die echte Auflösung erkennt. Dann gab es immer noch Probleme, dass der Kopfhörerausgang zum Beispiel nicht wechselt, wenn man einen Kopfhörer reinsteckt. Das erkennt er nicht automatisch, sondern gibt so ein kleines Zusatzprogramm. Es ist schon ein bisschen rumgewühlt und man muss schon ein bisschen hackbereit sein und sich ein bisschen aufwantar reinsetzen und in den Foren rumsuchen. Die Kamera zum Beispiel habe ich immer noch nicht am Laufen. Das eingebaute Mikrofon läuft nicht. USB-Mikros sind kein Problem. Was zu meinem erstaunen ohne Probleme geht, ist der SD-Card-Flot, den es hat. Da schiebt man eine SD-Card rein, dann startet iPhoto, als ob nichts gewesen wäre.
Überrascht mich auch weniger.
Der ist per USB angeschlossen intern.
Ja, das ist einfach so Standard-Hardware. Das ist dann auch...
Dieser WLAN-Treiber, ist das was Realtek da irgendwie, was die selber rausgegeben haben?
Genau, das ist dieser...
Das ist ja schon interessant, dass eine Firma irgendwie einen Treiber schreibt für...
Hardware, die es theoretisch gar nicht gibt.
Hardware, die es auf dem Mac gar nicht gibt, genau.
Also es sieht folgendermaßen aus, diese WLAN-Karte, die an einigen Geräten verbaut ist, ist eine Realtek-Karte und die wird von Mac OS nicht unterstützen. Jetzt gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder man kauft sich irgendwo bei Ebay oder sowas, eine billige, wird auch überall empfohlen, welche man da holen sollte, irgendeine von Dell, glaube ich.
Was heißt denn Karte? Wo steckt man denn hier Karten rein?
Das ist so eine Mini-PCI-Karte. Du musst unten einen Deckel abschrauben und dann kannst du die alte Karte rausnehmen und die neue reinpacken. Das ist auch relativ unaufwendig. Und mit der geht das dann. Mit der hat man dann, genauso wie auf dem Mac, hat man oben übers Airpods-Menü und dann kann man einfach ins WLAN. Das hab ich jetzt nicht gemacht, sondern ich hab mir diesen Realtek-Treiber aufgetrieben. Das ist so ein Programm, das muss man einmal installieren. Und das legt einen zusätzlichen virtuellen Ethernet-Port an und ein furchtbar hässliches Konfigurationsprogramm. Und das ist auch von der Usability her wirklich furchtbar, aber es funktioniert. Man kommt ins WLAN rein. Man muss jedes Mal, wenn man irgendwo hinkommt, also es ist nicht so wie bei macOS standardmäßig, dass er, ah, ich kenn doch das Netzwerk von früher, verbinde ich mich mal mit. Sondern man muss ihm sagen, du, verbinde dich mal wieder mit dem und dem Netzwerk. Das geht dann aber rasend schnell. Und dann ist man da im Netz. Was zu meiner absoluten Überraschung auch absolut problemlos ging, also ich hab mir das Ding, wie gesagt, geborgt. Ich weiß nicht, welche technischen Daten das hat, und dann hab ich irgendwie versehentlich auf so einer F-Taste herumgedrückt. Also ich wollte die WLAN-Karte ausschalten, den WLAN-Empfang, und dann leuchtete plötzlich so eine blaue LED auf. Dann hab ich gedacht, blau?
Die, der jetzt gerade leuchtet?
Nee, nee, hier unten, die, ich hab's jetzt abgeschaltet. Und dann ging Bluetooth an. Und dann hab ich gedacht, Bluetooth brauch ich eh nicht, wird wahrscheinlich nicht laufen, lief absolut ohne Probleme. Also das Mac OS hat sofort erkannt, dass da ein Bluetooth-Gerät ist, hat mir die entsprechenden Systemeinstellungen angezeigt, hat mir das Menü installiert, und ich hab's mit einer Bluetooth-Maus ausprobiert, mit der Apple-Bluetooth-Maus ging absolut ohne Probleme. Also es ist, vom Support her, was man alles hat, es ist ein gemischtwaren Geschäft, Sachen, wo man denkt, das soll doch kein Problem sein, die absolut problematisch sind, über Sachen, mit denen man wirklich nicht gerechnet hat, also wie Bluetooth, die dann absolut ohne Probleme gehen. Und ich bin so beeindruckt davon, dass ich mir das Ding jetzt, glaube ich, als Konferenzrechner und Table Book Rechner, Coffee Table Rechner zulegen werde. Oder beziehungsweise behalten werde.
Weil das jetzt hier nicht deiner ist.
Noch ist es nicht meiner, ich habe ihn quasi jetzt gebraucht gekauft.
Aber ich finde die Maus ein bisschen anstrengend.
Das Trackpad ist furchtbar. Also da weiß man, was man an Mac Trackpad hat. Das Trackpad ist sehr, sehr klein.
Das ist echt nicht zu überbrauchen. Ich finde die About Box sehr schön. Die Version heißt offiziell About-Box-Version-Format-String.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die erstaunlicherweise nicht funktionieren.
Erstaunlicherweise nicht funktionieren?
Naja, wo man nicht mit rechnet. Zum Beispiel das Tastaturkontrollfeld geht einfach nicht. Da rödelt der sich zur Tode. Man kann die Systemeinstellung problemlos schließen.
Aber das ist in der Tat überraschend.
Es geht einfach nicht. Es passiert gar nichts. Ich hab so diese Abbaubox, dass da nicht mal 10.56 drin steht, wundert mich ein bisschen.
Ist es das überhaupt?
Und das sind 10.56, ja.
Und erstmal eine Mathe nachtanken.
Ja, erstmal ein Stück nachtanken, ne.
Hast du dir das schon mal angeschaut, Dennis, vorhin?
Achso, und was ich noch habe ist...
Was denkst du denn darüber?
Also, die haben offensichtlich einen eigenen Kernel gebaut.
Das ist schon wieder zu viel Fumme. Also, ich bin ja schon voll der Fummler und bastel mir gerne Sachen zurecht. Aber wenn ich dann fertig bin mit dem Basteln, dann muss es auch gehen. Also, der Kernel-Panic-Fan hat mich schon ein bisschen verschrägt.
Also, er panikt deutlich öfter als ein echter Mac?
Also, wenn ich so ein Gewebe hätte, würde ich es auch machen. Aber jetzt mir extra einen dafür zu holen, glaube ich nicht, weil ich habe meinen Laptop eigentlich immer bei. Und wenn ich meinen Laptop nicht bei habe, habe ich schon vorher oft festgestellt, weil ich bin ja total internetabhängig, aber dann hole ich mir halt meine Mini-Dosis aus der Jackentasche und das nenne ich iPhone, das ist voll teuer.
Was ich aber jetzt hier bemerkenswert finde, ist, ich finde, mit der Screen-Größe könnte man durchaus arbeiten. Also, man ist schon so ein bisschen kleiner alles, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass es partout nicht geht.
Also, was ich wirklich erstaunlich fand, es nimmt sich von einer Geschwindigkeit mit so einem MacBook Air der ersten Generation nicht wirklich viel. Also, es hat jetzt so einen Atom-Prozessor da drinnen mit 1,6 Gigahertz, laut iStat sogar zwei Kern. Weiß ich nicht, ob das wirklich zwei Kern oder hat es nur einen Kern. Also, vom Prozessor her ist es natürlich schon zumindest offiziell deutlich langsamer als so ein MacBook Air. Man hat so ein MacBook Air, aber die erste Generation hat ja dieses Hitzeproblem, dass er gerne mal einen Kern abschaltet. Und dann komplett in die Knie geht. Was es relativ langsam macht und dieses Wind hat eine normale 2,5 Zoll Festplatte. Wohingegen das MacBook Air so eine 1,8er hat, die noch mal um einiges langsamer ist als so eine 2,5 Zoll Festplatte.
Ja, das ist in der Tat ein Nachteil bei dem Air. Vor allem bei der ersten Generation, wo es gar nicht so einfach ist, Abwärts zu kriegen.
Es hat einen Kern mit Hyperthreading, das weint, was dann für das Betriebssystem wie zwei Kerne erscheint. Und darum hatte ich auch oben bei iSense zwei Kerne.
Deswegen hast du auch hier eine CPU 2, genau. Wir tun mal so als ob...
Zum Surfen absolut okay. Google Earth lief drauf, relativ flüssig.
Echt?
Oder läuft drauf.
Aber was ist denn da für ein 3D-Stein drin?
Das ist Intel GMA950 heißt die Grafik.
Okay, also wie beim MacBook sozusagen.
Genau, also wie beim alten MacBook. Die dürfte relativ lahm sein. Externen Bildschirm hab ich noch gar nicht probiert. Sollte es wohl am Anfang ein paar Probleme gegeben haben mit Mirroring, dass man den nur als als zweiten Bildschirm benutzen konnte. Genau, so im ganz normalen VGA-Ausgang. Und ja, wie gesagt, sehr schönes Gerät. Tastatur ist echt okay.
Der Windscreen. Bompt ein bisschen, aber kann man durchaus benutzen.
Kann man, ich hab den jetzt...
Naja, ich mein so für 250 Euro.
Da kann man wirklich nicht meckern.
So ein bisschen der Wegwerfcomputer.
Ist so ein bisschen der Wegwerfcomputer. Ich benutze ihn auch so. Also ich hab den dann sehr gerne so benutzt, dass ich ihn einfach... Also ich mein das MacBook Pro hat man schon, oder den teuren Laptop, den hat man schon in einer großen Tasche drin, wo es auch ein bisschen gepolstert ist, damit nichts Böses passieren kann und dann hat man viel Zubehör dabei. Und das Ding ist schon eher so, ach Gott, das schmeiße ich mal hier in die Tasche rein und dann hat man so eine kleine Umhängetasche dabei auf diesem obsolaris Ding, wo ich ja nun auch ein bisschen mit rumgesessen habe und sogar teilweise zugehört. Ach so, Sleep-Modus ja. Ganz kurz zwischendurch taucht gerade im Chat auf. Hibernate geht nicht, aber Sleep-Modus geht. Und der Akku hält auch eine ganze Weile im Sleep-Modus. Und dafür ist das dann doch einfach so, wo man normalerweise, wo man sich nicht die Arbeit macht, den großen Mac mitzunehmen, aber wo man vielleicht unter Umständen in die Versuchung kommt, doch ein bisschen rumsurfen zu wollen oder so was, ist das glaube ich der richtige Rechner.
Ja, ich finde so zwischen so einem richtigen MacBook oder MacBook Pro sogar und einem iPhone, da muss auch irgendwie...
Da ist noch ein bisschen Platz.
Da ist irgendwie noch Platz. Also die Lücke kann geschlossen werden. Man sieht diese Netbook-Diskussion und Apple zieht sich ja jetzt auch schon seit Jahren dahin. Und ich meine, es ist nachvollziehbar, warum Apple in den Bereich jetzt so nicht reingeht.
Weil da keine Marge ist oder wie?
Ja, wie willst du in so einem 250-Dollar-Gerät irgendwie Geld verdienen?
Muss ja nicht 250 Dollar kosten.
Ne, muss es nicht. Die Frage ist, was darf es kosten? Ich finde ja, dass das eher derzeit einfach overpriced ist. Ich verstehe auch das nicht mehr so richtig, wenn man das eher mit dem MacBook vergleicht. Hat es eigentlich nur weniger Features, aber kostet halt mehr und nichts von dem, was es jetzt irgendwie ausmacht, ist jetzt so exklusiv. Also dieser Prozessor, den sie da am Anfang exklusiv hatten, ist jetzt mittlerweile nicht mehr so die Überraschung, oder? Sie könnten jetzt genauso gut auch auf diesen Atom-Prozessor ausweichen. Keine Ahnung, kenne ich jetzt bei den Prozessor-Generationen, die sie dort verwenden, nicht wirklich gut aus. Ich finde nur einfach, das R könnte auch weniger kosten. Also wenn sie das Ding nochmal um 500 Dollar senken würden, dann wäre das schon mal ganz interessant, aber derzeit ist es halt irgendwie teurer als ein MacBook, und das geht irgendwie gar nicht.
Also wenn das Ding hier, dieses Ding für 300 Euro machbar ist, dann müsste es möglich sein, für 800, 900 Euro mit einer ordentlichen Gewinnmarge ein wirklich vernünftiges Gerät zu bauen. Was hier in den Kommentaren nochmal Quatsch und Chat gerade gefragt wird, ist natürlich das BIOS-Update, wie ich das denn gemacht habe auf dem MSI, weil das war ein halbes Drama. Und zwar...
BIOS-Update.
Es wird da eh viel drin.
Nee, das ist ja jetzt ein gehacktes Mac OS, was auf einem normalen BIOS startet. Da wird aber ganz dringend empfohlen, unbedingt die neueste BIOS-Version vorher zu installieren. Die man, weil die ein bisschen stabiler ist und die erlaubt auch über Takten. Und daran habe ich wirklich mir komplett die Zähne ausgebissen, weil man lädt sich dieses BIOS-Update runter vom NSI und dann ist da eine kleine Anleitung als PDF dabei, wie man das zu tun hätte, dieses BIOS-Update. Und da steht dann drinnen, man nehme eine 3,5 Zoll Diskette. Echt? Und es steht dann so ganz klein, steht auch nebenbei, ja, als Fallback-Lösung kann man es auch von einem Memorystick machen. Aber es steht nicht, und man braucht einfach, man braucht nichts weiter als einen DOS-Boot-fähigen Memorystick. Aber es steht natürlich keine Anleitung dabei, woher soll ich so einen dämlichen DOS-Boot-baren Memorystick kriegen? Also hab ich mir eine Anleitung, hab ich im Netz ein bisschen rumgesucht. Es gibt von HP ein Tool, mit dem man unter Windows einen DOS, da tut es auch in 3DOS, kopieren kann auf einem Memorystick, und der ist dann bootbar, und damit ist alles super. Man kann ihn dann als FAD formatieren, außer dass er bei mir auf Teufelcom raus nicht als FAD formatieren wollte, sondern unbedingt auf FAD32.
Nicht auf was formatieren?
FAD, Data System, FAD, sondern auf FAD32. Und dann hab ich das, irgendwann bin ich auf die Idee gekommen, dass vielleicht so ein 8 GB Stick für einfachen FAD-Data System zu groß ist. Hab mit Mühe und Not noch irgendwo einen 1 GB Stick gefunden, und den konnte ich dann auch entsprechend formatieren, und dann konnte ich nach vielen Hin und Her auch von diesem Memory Stick booten und mein BIOS-Update machen, mit dem Ergebnis, dass ich keinen Unterschied festgestellt habe. Aber wird bestimmt einen haben. Also das ist echt mal, das ist, also Firmware-Updates sind ja auch bei Apple nicht gerade leicht, aber...
Find ich schon, dass sie leicht sind.
Na ja, dieses, und dann die Taste so lange gedrückt halten, bis er ganz laut piept und dann holt der Lifter auf und sowas. Ja, also es ist schon ein bisschen scary, aber kein Vergleich zu diesem Gerät, was einen zu das Ketten rät.
Zumindest muss man sich nicht mit technischen Details rumschlagen, außer jetzt irgendwie die Taste 5 Sekunden halten.
Immerhin, also wirklich, das ist...
Gut, also wer Hackintosh haben will, so könnte man das machen.
Bin ich jetzt wirklich glücklich mit bisher.
Tja, Dennis, du gehst ja auf 17 Zoll, wa?
15 Zoll.
Ja, das ist genau die goldene Mitte. Manchmal hätte ich auch gerne ein kleineres, manchmal hätte ich aber auch gerne ein größeres, deswegen ist 15 schon so genau richtig für mich. Ich fühl mich da voll wohl und ich greife dazu, wenn das nächste MacBook Pro rauskommt und ich hoffe, das hat dann mal 1680 oder mehr.
Ich glaub, das kommt dieses Jahr.
Der Juni schon wieder. Klar. Ich überlege, ob ich mein Firewire-Problem dadurch löse, dass ich mir ein neues MacBook kaufe und mein altes einfach nicht verkaufe. Aber so richtig eine Lösung ist es nicht. Ein Problem bin ich nämlich nicht losgeworden, dass das Ding hier die ganze Zeit irgendwie lüftet. Ich glaub, der ist auch wie im Eimer.
Du hast doch tausend Sachen offen. Hast du denn vier Gigabyte drin oder?
Tausend Sachen offen. Ich meine, das Ding lüftet auch, wenn er auf 5% rumeidet.
Mehr als sonst, oder?
Er kommt relativ schnell ins Bild.
War das bei dir, wo der Tisch und das Ding kaputtgegangen war?
Ahja, krass.
Naja, der Tisch spaltet sich, weil das Gerät immer so heiß ist und immer an derselben Stelle steht. Vielleicht sollte ich mir mal so einen Stand holen, aber dann ist die Tastatur immer so gut.
Also ich hab festgestellt, dass wenn ich schon mein Mac irgendwie da so ein Minimäßiges drunterlege, eine CD-Hülle zum Beispiel, so hinten unter der letzte Kante, wo es so leicht schräg angehoben steht hinten, das spart dir schon 1000 Umdrehungen circa. Da geht der Lüfter gleich ein Stück runter.
Echt?
Ja, weil der dann besser hinten abpusten kann.
Das stimmt natürlich.
Weil so mit dem Display macht sich das hinten fast so ein bisschen zu und wenn du es so ein ganz bisschen hochhebst, dann kann er da voll super lüften.
Echt hast du? Ich mach das gleich mal.
Das hab ich früher mal bei einem Powerbook gemacht.
Ja, ist halt nur ein bisschen nervig halt so auf Dauer, aber funktioniert auf jeden Fall.
Sieht schicker aus.
Ja, ist halt dann teilweise halt dann doch ein bisschen wackelig so, wobei...
Ich finde, Apple könnte eigentlich auch so eine Schwebefunktion einbauen.
Das ist natürlich.
Ja, iFloat. Dass das Ding einfach immer so ein Fingerdick über dem Tisch schwebt.
Es garantiert schon fertig, müssen sie bloß noch die...
Marketingmaterialien fertigstellen?
Namen, sie haben doch keinen Namen. Wie das Ladeproblem lösen, das wollte ich jetzt sagen.
Das Ladeproblem?
Na ja, wie wenn man dann immer noch ein Kabel abhängt. Das ist dann so auffällig, wenn man so weit runterhängt. Das war der Versuch in das Bizzare, das kommt nicht wieder vor. Ich hatte übrigens... Wer hat das vor was genau? Hat im Chat noch ein paar Fotos gepostet. Hat jemand im MSI in weißes sogar noch ein Äpfelchen eingebaut?
Ein Apfel eingebaut.
Der sogar leuchtet, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Das brauchst du aber auch unbedingt noch.
Total. Ich glaube, bei mir tut es auch ein Aufkleber.
Gut, haben wir denn noch andere spannende Themen? Was ist passiert?
Es gibt ein neues Transmission Beta, 1.5 Beta 4.
Oh, das klingt ja wie das Release, auf das wir alle gewartet haben.
Ja, ist ein bisschen so. Weil da haben sich ordentlich Leute beschwert, dass Transmission nicht so toll wäre. Jetzt gibt es ja auch diesen Micro-Torrent Beta. Und dann gibt es ja Leute, die kommen so in einen Work-Channel, wo die Transmission-Developer rumhängen und sagen, ja hier, Micro-Torrent voll super, Transmission irgendwie geht gar nichts, aber Micro-Torrent voll super. Damit können die Developer halt natürlich nicht viel anfangen, aber die...
Wieso jetzt? Moment, hat das was zu tun mit dieser ganzen UDP-Geschichte oder was? Warum meinen die, dass das so toll sei? Micro-Torrent.
Weil es besser lief. Mehr Connections, mehr Peers, mehr Daten. Das sagen die erstmal nicht. Die User kommen und sagen, hier, Micro-Torrent besser und Transmission nicht mehr. Transmission hat jetzt mal ein bisschen Konkurrenz, wo die Leute mal vergleichen können. Und dann haben die Developer, naja, du musst schon ein bisschen genauer sagen. Die sagen, wissen wir nicht, aber ich sehe doch, es ist doch da besser. Und naja, dann haben sich die Anfragen schon ein bisschen geholft und dann haben sie doch mal ein bisschen geforscht und gemacht und getan, habe ich auch ein bisschen mitgeholfen und so. Und dann hat er irgendwie, ich glaube, am Ende drei oder vier Sachen gefunden, wo halt wirklich auch schon ein Code, der richtig uralt ist, wo es einfach falsch ist. Und hat er alles gefixt. Und jetzt, Transmission rockt jetzt wie es auch. Echt? Also man will jetzt die 1.5 Beta 4 fahren, die neuest Version. Aber, jetzt wird es noch ein bisschen tricky. Seit der Version 1.5 unterstützt Transmission auch IPv6. Dank unserem Freund Erdgeist, der ja auch den OpenTracker Software schreibt, hat er noch ein paar Bugs gefunden, die da drin hatten, damit es überhaupt erstmal ging. Seit 1.5 Beta 2 geht es auch bei denen. Und das Problem ist, dass auch Pirate Bay jetzt einen Tracker hat, der unter IPv6 lauscht, hat der Erdgeist auch geschrieben, sind ja da mal vorher an beiden Seiten am Machen. Und jetzt ist das Problem, dass wenn man IPv6 hat, dann connectet das Transmission zu diesem IPv6-Tracker. Und der hat halt nur IPv6-Adressen drin, von anderen Leuten, die auch IPv6 haben. Das heißt, man kriegt aber keine IPv4-Adressen von dem IPv6-Tracker. Aber Transmission connectet halt nur einmal. Weil es resolviert halt auch nur einmal nach IPv6. Das heißt, wenn man IPv6 hat und Transmission 1.5 Beta 4 benutzt, kriegt man keine PS, weil kommt kein IPv4 an. Solange der Pirate Bay Tracker im Torrent eingetragen ist. Das heißt, das ist noch so ein bisschen das Problem und das ist noch ein bisschen nervig und ein bisschen blöd. Das wird hoffentlich vor Ende, also wenn das Final rauskommt von 1.5, wird es hoffentlich noch gefixt. Ich hab dir gesagt, das müsst ihr machen, sonst heulen die Leute alle rum. Aber wir wollten die Sache auch mal ein bisschen pushen. Also wer keinen IPv6 hat...
Warum kann der Tracker nicht sowohl V4-Adressen...
Na, das ist eine längere Geschichte. Das sollte getrennt bleiben. Also das ist absichtlich. Weil es sind eigentlich zwei verschiedene Wolken.
Also man läuft dann ganz schön alleine, oder?
Mit nur IPv4, ja. Aber es wäre kein Problem. Der Transmission könnte einfach die Adresse zweimal resolven, nämlich IPv4 und IPv6 und sein...
Sowohl als auch.
Genau. Macht er jetzt leider noch nicht. Das ist das Problem. Und dann bleibt man halt beim IPv6 hängen und kriegt keine Peers. Aber jeder, der keinen IPv6 hat, kann es 1.5.4 locker benutzen und kriegt reichlich mehr Peers oder verliert es auch nicht. Also da gab es mehrere Probleme. Und, ja, sollte dann super laufen.
Oder Azureos einfach.
Und verbraucht, was auch noch war, verbraucht auch reichlich weniger Ressourcen, also CPU-Power, weil so ein Torrent besteht ja aus Pieces. Und jetzt gibt es ja hier, keine Ahnung, wenn man sich jetzt zum Beispiel so ein, gibt es ja Leute, die laden ja ganze Staffeln runter, die sind nur so 30 GB groß, oder so ein Blu-ray-Film oder was auch immer, die so runterladen, diese Urlaubsfilme, sagen wir ja immer. Und zum Beispiel. Und wenn die halt ganz viele Pieces haben, dann war halt die Funktion, die da durchschleicht, um rauszufinden, was jetzt interessant ist und welche Pieces man mit den anderen tauschen möchte, die war total langsam. Und umso mehr Pieces das waren, umso langsamer wurde es. Und das hat dann mal ordentlich beschleunigt und ist die Load gleich ordentlich runtergegangen von Transmission. Also wenn man nur kleine Torrents runterlädt, dann verbraucht es fast gar keine CPU mehr.
Also ich hab hier vor ein paar Tagen bei mir IPv6 ausgeschaltet, deswegen hast du das vorhin auch bemerkt, weil ich das Problem hatte, dass ich an bestimmte Webseiten einfach nicht mehr rankam mit dem automatischen IPv6-Tunnel, den meine AirPod Extreme bzw. Time-Klipschül aufbaut. Das war mir neu.
Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum Google sich nicht traut, irgendwie google.com ist es, oder? Nicht Org. Org gibt es auch, aber es ist was anderes. Die, die sich nicht trauen, einzuschalten, weil es bei vielen Leuten einfach nicht mehr funktionieren würde, weil es mit dem IPv6 noch nicht so richtig schick ist. Sache ist natürlich aber auch, dass es nicht schick ist, wird ja verborgen, indem sie es nicht einschalten. Aber dann wird es auch keiner fixen, weil da ist das Problem halt einfach nicht da. Und das ist halt so ein bisschen blöd. Ich finde, die großen Firmen sollten mal sagen, alles klar, ab Juli oder irgendwie so werden wir, und zwar nicht nur eine Firma, weil dann ist halt nur die schuld, dann muss die das halt ausbaden, dann sagen alle, Google geht nicht, sondern alle großen Firmen sollten vielleicht irgendwann mal sagen, wir schalten jetzt alle ein. Von mir aus 2010, erste, erste.
Den Konsens wirst du nicht hinbekommen, glaube ich.
Das muss ja kein Konsens sein, das müssen nur genug große Firmen finden, die das halt machen. Und Pirate Bay hat jetzt mal angefangen.
Pirate Bay ist aber auch nicht eine große Firma.
Pirate Bay ist Platz 169 der weltweit top besuchten Sites.
Ja, aber bestimmt nicht im Umsatz.
Wer interessiert Umsatz?
Na ja, große Firmen interessiert Umsatz.
Ja, aber es spielt doch bei IPv6 keine Rolle, was der Umsatz betrug.
Nein, aber die Firmen interessiert natürlich ihr Umsatz. Und was passiert, wenn der Google nicht umwirbt? Das haben wir ja vor ein paar Tagen wunderbar gesehen, als Google mal 40 Minuten lang sich irgendwie slash in die Weite ist.
Gibt es da Statistiken, wie viele Werbungskosten, die da verdienst haben? Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch mal kurz sagen, was passiert ist, für die Leute, die das nicht mitbekommen haben. Google hat ja so eine Blacklist mit drin, wo Sites, wo man weiß, oder wo man Grund hat zu vermuten, dass dort Malware im Web liegt. Das heißt, wenn da Windows-Büchsen draufsurfen, die klicken da, dann fangen die sich halt in einen automatischen Exploit ein, wenn sie einen alten Browser verwenden und so weiter. Und dann kommt böse Malware und dann ist man Teil eines Botnetzes. Und das ist so eine Liste von URLs. Und irgendein Freddy hat es geschafft, da so einen Slash einzutragen. Also sozusagen Maps Everything. Und dann war halt für 40 Minuten lang jede Webseite, also jedes Ergebnis bei Google...
Also jede OL, die einen Slash hat und das...
Jede...
.haben alle.
Ja, genau. War This Site May Harm Your Computer.
Genau, sogar Google selbst.
Einschließlich Google selbst, genau. Und ich hab zwei Graphen gesehen. Eine von einem deutschen Unternehmen, was sehr offensichtlich auf Google angewiesen ist, um so, damit die Leute zu ihnen finden. Und da war ein massiver Einbruch. Auch bei der Wikipedia waren es, glaube ich, so 20, 30 Prozent gefühlt. Ich hab den Graph leider nicht abgespeichert, nur kurz gesehen. Also Leute waren massiv abgeschreckt. Wenn wir jetzt vorstellen, Google schaltet mal IPv6 an, ich glaube, dann wäre das ähnlich.
Ja, aber dann würden sie es vielleicht auch mal fixen.
Ja, gut, aber dann, weißt du, wenn die das einschalten, dann ist einfach 10 Minuten später, haben die dann eine Diskussion im Flur, da musst du dich dann auch erstmal stellen. Und wenn du da irgendwie stehst, und irgendwie die ganze Welt kommt auf dich zu und sagt, unser Business funktioniert nicht mehr und wir gehen jetzt in 20 Minuten pleite. Und du stehst da mit, naja Leute, kommt mal klar, das muss jetzt mal gefixt werden. Wir müssen irgendwie unsere Torrenten oder so was tragen.
Also mir hat ja ein Vögelchen gezwitschert, das in Berlin im Sommer, nee, das in Berlin im Sommer IPv6 irgendwie deployed werden soll.
Was heißt in Berlin?
Ja bei dieser Firma halt.
Ein Provider?
Ja, so ein Carrier würde ich das fast eher nennen. Ja, Provider auch beides. Und da hab ich gesagt, das machen die ja nicht, achso, Ende des Jahres in Deutschland. Und da meinte ich, das machen die ja nicht einfach so. Da sind doch bestimmt, weil die anderen Firmen das dann auch bald vorhaben. Und da meinte er, ja genau, das ist der Grund, weil die Konkurrenz Ähnliches vorhat. Also das heißt, das geht dieses Jahr los mit IPv6.
Sodass es auch zum End-User deployed wird?
Ja sicher, darum geht's ja. Das wäre das Ding. Also eigentlich ist es jetzt für den Endanwender nicht so wirklich spannend, bis auf die Tatsache, er kriegt feste Adressen. Ich weiß aber schon gar nicht mehr, ob das für den Endanwender wirklich toll ist, weil wenn, also bisher ist es ja so, wenn du drei Rechner zu Hause hast, dann hast du halt so ein Nut dazwischen und deine Rechner sind schon durch dieses Nut, das wirkt so wie eine Art Firewall, kommt man halt nicht zu den Rechnern durch und alles ist sicher, einigermaßen. Das ist bei IPv6, wenn man halt irgendwie, da kriegt man halt gleich ein ganzes Netz, weil es gibt halt so viele Adressen, dann sind die Rechner nicht mehr automatisch hinter so einer Art Firewall und man müsste sich halt mal drum kümmern. Wenn das nicht gemacht wird, dann steht alles offen wie ein Scheunentör. Also mir ist als Mac-User so fast ein bisschen egal, aber die ganzen Windows-Kisten, die werden ja erschossen sofort. Wie weit, 17 Sekunden oder was?
Ja, das kann schon sein, aber letzten Endes sehe ich das auch nicht als das große Problem an. Also hier bei der Time Capsule, wenn ich da IPv6 anschalte, dann kann ich auch gleich Firewall-Settings sagen. Die sind bei Default auf Block Incoming Connections. Das heißt, über IPv6 geht dann einfach mal gar nichts rein. Beziehungsweise muss der Default sein, weil letzten Endes brauchst du ja auch einen Router. In dem Moment, wo dein Provider IPv6 anbietet, heißt das ja noch lange nicht, dass es gleich bei deinem Rechner landet. Sondern da sind tonnenweise Fritz-Boxen, die wahrscheinlich von IPv6 noch nichts gehört haben.
Ich hoffe, das muss erst mal angepasst werden. Also es kommt dann, wenn ich es richtig verstanden hab, auch über PPP rein, PPP, und dann hat man es. Und da wird dann aber nicht eine Adresse zugewiesen, sondern ein ganzes Netz. Und zwar, wenn ich es richtig verstanden hab, also bisher, ich hab ja auch schon so ein Tunnel und so, da krieg ich einen Slash 64. Das heißt, dass man als Privatanwender am Ende ein Netz kriegt, was zwei hoch 64 Adressen hat.
Zwei hoch 64.
Ja, doch.
Der Club hat einen 2 hoch 40. Und davon krieg ich, das ist ja, also, ne, den Slash 40, das heißt, ne Rest, also, mmh, 2 hoch 88. Wie auch immer. Jedenfalls wird es halt zum Ende hin immer weniger, aber 2 auf 64 bleibt für den Endanwender übrig.
Oh man, ist schon eine Weile her, dass ich mit der IPv6 beschäftigt habe. Ich muss mal einen, ich glaub, ich muss mal einen... Jaja, steht schon länger auf meiner Liste.
Also es wird auf jeden Fall, wenn es so stimmt, und die Timings oder wie sagt man, die Deadlines gehalten werden können, dann soll das irgendwann diesen Sommer stattfinden.
Hm, naja, gut, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall, du hast schon recht, das wird eine Menge Ärger bringen. Was ich allerdings nicht verstehe, ist, warum bei mir das jetzt so viel Ärger macht. Ich hatte zum Beispiel ganz konkret das Problem mit Python, mit der Python-Org-Webseite. Die konnte ich einfach über IPv6 nicht erreichen. Und mir war nicht klar, warum.
Also über IPv6 oder per IPv6?
Das Ding ist, wenn ich IPv6 auf meinem Router einschalte, dann schnappt sich mein Mac OS X IPv6.
Python-Org hat eine IPv6-Adresse.
Genau. Und dann ist auch gleich alles IPv6. Alles, was GUI ist, macht dann automatisch IPv6, sofern es selber IPv6 kann.
Also dein Mac macht auch, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, wenn du schon bei dir hier deinen, wie sagt man, File Browsing, also deinen Fileshare aufmachst, dass ich was bei dir in die Dropbox legen kann. Und mein Rechner sieht dich. Das ist schon alles über IPv6 unten drunter.
Ja, an der Stelle ist das alles wunderbar. Nur das Zusammenspielen im Internet ist so eine Sache. Also was so ein Fehler ist, den ich mal hatte und wo ich dann auch am Anfang glaubte, das wäre jetzt das Problem bei Python, das war es dann aber nicht, dass Leute eine IPv6-Adresse für ihren Server broadcasten, also resolven, aber der Server läuft nicht auf dem Socket. Und denselben Effekt hatte ich auch mit python.org, bloß von woanders ging es zu dem Zeitpunkt. Also es war mein spezifischer Tunnel, den ich benutzt habe. Durch den kam es nicht durch. Andere Leute, die IPv6 hatten, da ging es. Und das Problem habe ich nicht gelöst bekommen. Das ist jetzt mal ausgeschaltet. Das habe ich ausgeschaltet, weil ich davon auch ausgehen musste, dass ich jetzt am laufenden Meter in irgendwelche Webseiten reinrenne, die einfach nichts von sich geben. Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen uncool. Also das ganze Debugging, das wird auch noch schwierig.
Vor allem halt die, keine Ahnung, wie viele Jahre, bestimmt mehrere, fünf oder so, wo wir halt dual fahren müssen. Also wahrscheinlich reichlich mehr als fünf. Und das wird ein bisschen tricky. Am Anfang wird es tricky, weil man auf IPv6 einsteigen muss in der Mitte. Das ist einigermaßen okay, weil sich alle darauf geeinigt haben, dass es parallel fahren. Und am Ende wird es dann noch mal krass, wenn dann halt bestimmte Services nur noch in IPv6 zur Verfügung stehen und das wiederum noch nicht alle haben und so weiter und so fort. Also es wird noch mal eine interessante Sache.
Hast du schon Click-to-Flash installiert? Das ist toll. Also es gibt ja bei Kamino, gab es diese Funktionalität schon ewig. Aber irgendjemand hat jetzt irgendeinen Open Source-Teil rausgehauen, was sich dann gleich die Community geschnappt hat. Und dann hat sich das Ding jetzt in der letzten Woche gleich mit drei Versionsschritte weiterentwickelt. Es ist einfach ein Plugin für WebKit. Was halt im Safari funktioniert, aber auch in allen anderen WebKit-Anwendungen.
Dieses Ding klickt Flash, das heißt, das blendet die Flash-Dinge aus und man muss erst anklicken, bevor die gestartet haben.
Genau, das überlädt sozusagen den Mime-Type. Oder kriegt es automatisch zugesprochen, weil es sich nur für einen von zwei meldet. Keine Ahnung, wie es sich da vordrängelt. Auf jeden Fall kriegt es das. Und dann hast du erstmal so ein Plain Image, wo einfach nur Flash drauf steht. Und dann, wenn du draufklickst, dann delegiert er das an das eigentliche Flash-Plugin. Das heißt, dann lädt behauptet erst das Flash-Plugin. Was den Vorteil hat, also es ist nicht nur so, dass irgendwie die Flash-Filme geladen und nicht gestartet werden, sondern es ist auch, dieses Flash-Plugin als solches wird nicht aktiv. Was halt alle Vorteile hat, die man sich da so denkt, weil es läuft dann halt einfach auch dieser Code nicht, belegt keine CPU und nix.
Ist der Grund, warum ich damals von Safari weg bin.
Wo ist das Ding?
Click to Flash ein Wort.
Das ist so ein GitHub, da der dritte Punkt leider erst bei...
Ja, komischerweise ist das bei Google... Der hat sich das unter den Nagel gerissen und dann...
Das kommt mal ganz runter und da ist die Version 1.3 zum Download.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Übrigens bei dem Webkit, da gibt es seit einer Weile Sparkle Updates. Also ich nutze ja nicht Safari, sondern das Webkit Nightly-Bild. Und früher musste ich es immer von Hand runterladen, aber man wurde beim Starten von Safari immer schon dran erinnert, dass da schon eine neue Version liegt, weil die Nightly-Bild-Homepage war immer die Startseite von dem Webkit. Und aber inzwischen poppt da so ein Ding hoch irgendwie, hier Sparkle, willst du, sagst du Yes, lehrt das runter, sagst du mal Yes, install and relaunch, zack, ist voll toll.
Ja, das ist voll toll. Das ist auch der Grund, warum bei mir Webkit jetzt mein Default-Browser geworden ist. Weil ich jetzt das sozusagen immer aktuell halten kann, relativ easy.
No.
Click to flash is not installed.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine echte Freude.
Also das nimmt so viel CPU-Last vom Rechner. So, dann muss ich den Webcode kurz einmal ausmachen, wieder einschalten, ja, oder noch nicht. Weiß nicht, hab ich jetzt einfach mal gemacht. Und wo haben wir jetzt mal Flash? Bei YouTube zum Beispiel, ja?
Genau. Eigentlich hast du überall Flash. Das finde ich auch so schön, dass einem überhaupt nicht klar wird, wo, überall.
Und dann ist halt so ein Bildchen drin und da muss man dann noch einmal draufklicken, das war's schon.
Genau, und dann geht's so weiter, wie es sonst gegangen wäre.
Voll toll.
Du kannst dann auch vorher mit irgendwie Secondary-Click da draufgehen und die Whitelist editieren. Leider geht die Whitelist immer von der Enclosing-Webseite aus. Also, kannst nicht generell sagen, YouTube-Filme sollen immer...
Also ich hab ja halt keine Adblocker mehr, weil die haben mir immer zu viel rumgezickt. Jetzt gehste zu Spiegel und dann kommt zwar oben und an der Seite alles in Magenta von so einer komischen Firma, die irgendwie Patente auf Farben hat oder so immer. Und dann steht einfach nur Flash drin.
So sieht's aus.
Ich find's super, wie ihr euch freut darüber, dass... Ja, ich weiß.
Du hast halt Firefox und da sieht man das alles nicht.
Da gibt's dir das Flashblock.
Nee, Firefox ist mir immer noch zu komisch irgendwie.
Ja, mir auch.
Naja, dann lieber das unkomische Flashblock heißt das bei FireFox. Flashblock ist eine Extension, die man sich sehr einfach unterladen kann. Und bei Kaminos ist es ja von vornherein dabei. Ich glaube, es ist genau der gleiche. Driver Scriptcode sieht auf jeden Fall sehr gut aus.
Ja, ich glaube auch, so hieß das Ding.
Hier habe ich mir jetzt extra 4 GB gekauft, von denen drei ja übrig sind. Und jetzt brauche ich das doch alles nicht, weil die Flashes mir jetzt gar nicht mehr meinen Speicher wegkauen. Ist ja lame.
Tja, dann kannste mir Bittorn fahren. Ist doch schön, oder?
Ja, ist voll geil.
Oder per Flasherzeige bei Ebay verkloppen.
So, iPhone 2.2.1 Update kam.
Ist voll toll, habe ich mir sofort runtergeladen, weil da war der Bucket-Fix, den ich hatte. Na, wenn du irgendwie ein Bild hast und dir da ein Wallpaper von machst, zum Beispiel, dann musst du das so komisch skalieren. Also bei bestimmten Bildgrößen war das das Problem. Und dann hatste hier, ich habe hier so ein schickes Bild von so einer Fotografin wie das hier.
Porno.
Das ist Kunst.
Ich mach nur Witze.
Kunst ist das.
Art nennt man das heutzutage im Neudeutsch.
Wenn es schwarz-weiß ist, ist es Kunst.
Genau.
Art.
Jedenfalls waren da voll Treppcheneffekte. Der hat irgendwie einen Fehler an der Skalierung gehabt. Und zwar aber nur auch beim Konvertieren. Das eigentliche Bild, das gespeichert war auf dem iPhone, war alles prima, aber für das Wallpaper, wo es von der Größe hat angepasst, und dann hat es so voll böse Treppcheneffekte, war alles so komisch, als wenn es eigentlich vorher kleiner war und hochgezogen wurde, obwohl es eigentlich größer war. Und das wurde mit diesem Update auf jeden Fall gefixt. Hab ich es gleich nochmal, das Bild hatte ich ja noch, nochmal gesetzt als Wallpaper und schwupp, seitdem ist der Popo glatt.
Aber, aber eigentlich haben sie, sie haben auch Spaceband geupdatet, ne?
Nicht bei dem alten. Bei dem neuen haben sie das geupdatet, beim alten nicht. Beim alten ist alles weiterhin so wie immer und deswegen konnte man auch einfach updaten, ohne irgendwie den Unlock zu verlieren, nur das Jailbreak war weg. Jetzt inzwischen aber gibt es ja die neuen Versionen auch alle.
Was heißt denn, es gibt ein neues Jailbreak? Das heißt, dass sie einen anderen Exploit gefunden haben? Oder gibt es eine Methode, mit dem sie...
Das weiß ich nicht. Nee, ich glaub nicht. Dazu kam es zu schnell raus.
Für den Jailbreak brauchen sie ja keinen Exploit zu finden?
Nicht mehr? Nee, stimmt. Haben sie ja irgendwie anders umgangen, ne?
Genau, das sind sie ja schon eine ganze Weile. Können sie ja ohne Exploit den... Oder den haben sie einmal gefunden und den macht Apple auch nicht mehr dicht. Meinst du? Ich glaube, es ist schlichteingreifend technisch nicht möglich. Apple kommt so tief nicht mehr rein.
Ne, ne, ne. Da verwechselst du gerade was. Was du meinst, wo sie nicht mehr reinkommen ist, dass sie den Bootloader von dem alten iPhone haben sie aufgehackt. Und den könnte Apple nur ändern, indem sie halt ein Bootloader-Update fürs alte Telefon rausbringen. Das hat Apple aber noch nie gemacht, dass sie den Bootloader flashen, was aber gehen würde. Aber man müsste das halt einfach nicht machen, weil der Bootloader funktioniert ja so und da muss man halt einfach nur nicht mehr rangehen. Und deswegen meinen sie, kann Apple da nicht ran. Zur Zeit, wie sie aber den Jailbreak machen, bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher, weil dieses Quick Pawn macht ja auch irgendwie mit so einem Image-Mounting beim Booten irgendwas. Ich glaube, das würden die schon noch dicht kriegen. Weil die Frage, ob dann nicht auch das ganze iTunes umgestellt werden müsste und so weiter und so fort.
Ah, super. Jetzt sind wir natürlich mal wieder schön an die Falle getrappt. Das war jetzt nicht haargenau wissen, wovon wir sprechen.
Ausnahmsweise mal wissen wir nicht haargenau, wovon wir sprechen.
Oder eigentlich überhaupt nicht. Also auf jeden Fall gibt es ja der Unlock für das 3G-iPhone, der mit Yellow Snow gemacht wurde und bei der Firmware 2.2 seit Anfang Januar sehr schön funktioniert hat. Wohl. Oder nicht sehr schön, aber immer besser. Der ist erstmal wieder außen vor, weil sie müssen einen Exploit im Baseband finden. Das heißt, wenn man unbedingt auf 2.2.1 es aktualisieren will und man hat ein iPhone mit Yellow Snow oder will irgendwann mal Yellow Snow installieren, also um z.B. was anderes als eine Telekom-Karte zu verwenden, dann muss man sich eine Custom Firmware bauen, ein Custom Firmware-Update, nicht mit dem Quick Pwn-Tool, sondern unbedingt mit dem echten Pwnage-Tool. Und da kann man dann wählen, welche Baseband-Version man gerne hätte. Und da muss man dann die alte Baseband-Version belassen.
Das heißt, man kriegt sozusagen das neue OS, aber noch die alte Baseband-Version?
Weil in der danach haben sie es halt schon zugemacht, das Loch, ne?
In der danach, in der aktuellen Version, ist dieses Loch zugemacht.
Also kann man sagen, dass 221 eigentlich eine Reaktion auf den Kongress war?
Das kann man, könnte man so formulieren, ja.
Wieso? Das 2-2 war ja... Achso, nee, stimmt. Sie haben gesagt, man soll kein 2-2 installieren. Dann kam aber der Unlock und der war dann doch für 2-2. Ja, könnte sein.
Dass sie einfach das Loch zugemacht haben, was sie da genutzt haben? Tja, das heißt, beim 3G ist es Ihnen doch wichtig, ich schätze dann mal im Juni, wenn das nächste iPhone rauskommt, dann...
Ja, bei dem alten können sie halt wirklich nichts mehr machen, außer sie ändern jetzt den Bootloader und dann würden sie dann sagen, das iPhone-Dev-Teen sagt dann allen Leuten, Jungs, updatet euren Bootloader nicht. Und der Bootloader ist mal total unrichtig, den muss man nicht updaten. Der macht ja nichts weiter als das Image hochzuziehen. Also dann halt der Spaceband und so weiter. Und da muss man einfach nichts tun.
Hast du dir jetzt eigentlich den iPhone-Vortrag vom Kongress mal angeschaut? Noch nicht zugekommen? Ich auch nicht.
Doch, wäre ich. Aber das war doch, das ist doch, weil die iPhone-Dev-Team-Jungs wollten wohl nicht gefilmt werden oder so was. Und deswegen sieht man nur die Slides. Und die Slides waren noch irgendwie so überkontrastet. Oder irgendwie so, man konnte fast nichts lesen.
Nee, es gibt Versionen, die sind lesbar.
Von der anderen Kamera oder was?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was da als erstes war. Es haben ja die ersten Versionen, die im Netz waren, waren ja die Grabs von den Streams. Und keine Ahnung, wer da irgendwie was falsch gemacht hat. Auf jeden Fall gibt's eine lesbare Version von dem Vortrag. Ich hab ja jetzt auch den Podcast-Feed mit den Kongress-Videos online. Bei chaosradio.ch. Gibt's jetzt sozusagen.
Hab ich ja letztens gesehen, hast du die letzte Woche auch noch gepostet, ne?
Genau.
Hab ich auch schon weiter gedingst.
Muss ich natürlich nochmal jemanden finden, der mir dann alles nochmal in meinem Format irgendwie encoded. Aber das ist geschehen. Ja, Jungs.
War's das schon?
Ich hab jetzt nur noch langweiler Themen, die würd ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig zumuten.
Na ich will noch was aufgreifen. Wir haben ja bisher so ein bisschen über dieses Open-Cell erzählt. Und wenn ich es jetzt richtig gestern verstanden hab, weil bei uns im Club ist jemand, der sich mit beschäftigt, oder schon 2, 3 inzwischen, und der eine davon hat auch ein Mac und hat mir irgendwie gezeigt, wie er mit, ist noch nicht Open-Cell, sondern ist halt cruder, was von NVIDIAs. Was, wenn ich es gestern richtig verstanden hab, wohl die Grundlage für das Open-Cell ist. Also gab's ja zwei Parallel-Entwicklungen.
Richtig.
Also, müssen wir nochmal erzählen, was das alles ist?
Also Open-Cell ist jetzt sozusagen der Standard für Computing auf 3D-Grafikkarten. Oder auf Grafikkarten. Und damit nutzt man sozusagen diese Möglichkeiten der Karte. Und CL ist einfach eine Abstraktion, die herstellerübergreifend sein soll, die also auch ATI implementieren kann. Bei NVIDIA, das worauf Apple jetzt vor allem setzt.
Na alle, nicht nur Apple. Also du meinst, Apple setzt jetzt auf NVIDIA als Grafikkarte?
Richtig, Apple setzt jetzt auf NVIDIA. Viele andere tun das vielleicht auch, aber nicht ausschließlich. Wir würden uns ja auch durchaus damit zurechnen, dass ATI irgendwann mal wieder zurückkommt.
Und die sitzen ja auch mit im OpenCL-Boot. Die sind aufgesprungen. Wahrscheinlich war deren Implementation nicht so toll und die haben sich halt auf dieses OpenCL geeinigt.
Alle machen OpenCL. Es sieht sehr danach aus, dass es sozusagen ein Erfolg wird gleich vom Start weg. Und auch das iPhone wird ja wahrscheinlich OpenCL bekommen. Diese PowerVR-Bude, die den 3D-Stein fürs iPhone macht, da hat sich Apple ja auch mit beteiligt. Jetzt bei der Firma. Und was ich gelesen habe, ist, dass eben, es auch sehr wahrscheinlich ist, dass die OpenCL-Abstraktion eben für einen zukünftigen Prozessor, wo das drin ist, eben auch zur Verfügung steht. Was natürlich total sinnvoll ist. Also man kann davon... Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt sozusagen schon für das nächste iPhone gelten wird, was jetzt im Juni rauskommt. Mich wird es nicht überraschen, wenn da schon der erste Custom-Prozessor drin ist, den Apple eben jetzt mit seiner eigenen Bude entwickelt hat.
Jedenfalls hat mir der Mac-User gestern gezeigt, der hatte irgendwie so ein Fenster offen, da war so eine Art grüne Suppe drin und der konnte mit der Maus reingreifen, konnte so hin und her ziehen und dann ist das... Die Suppe hat sich halt so live irgendwie wie so ein physikalisches Modell hin und her verschoben oder hatte irgendwie so ein Blobbel aus 8.000 kleinen Objekten, die halt durch die Gegend geflogen sind oder sich zusammengezogen haben und so und das wurde alles über dieses Cuda berechnet, also weil OpenCell gibt es ja noch nicht. Und der hatte halt sich dieses Cuda installiert, was es für ein Mac halt gibt von NVIDIA, irgendwie in der Version 2.1 gibt es es schon oder auch 2.0, früher 1.1. Und dann hast du irgendwie so einen Compiler, wenn ich es richtig verstanden hab, hieß der NVCC, wahrscheinlich NVIDIA C-Compiler. Das ist auch einigermaßen, sieht so voll nach C-Code aus. Ist aber dann halt für die einzelnen Cores auf so einem Grafikchip, auf so einer GPU. Und davon hast du irgendwie mehrere und die wiederum mit ganz vielen Threads. Und wenn du denen ordentlich paralysierbare Arbeiten gibst, dann rattert die Karte das runter mit, also unglaublich schnell. Der Gäste meinte, der hätte irgendwie was berechnen können mit 40 Gigaflops.
Wie viele Gigaflops haben wir denn so normalerweise auf unserem Prozessor in der Zeit?
Na, wenn man pro Takt irgendwie eine Operation hinkriegt, dann kriegst du halt bei zwei Gigas zwei Gigaflops. Wenn es mal so ist. Da ist 40 Gigaflops schon nicht so schlecht. Und der hat jetzt nicht so eine Power-Grafikarte in seinem, der hatte eine 17 Zoll MacBook Pro. Also, das geht auch noch schneller.
Du hast ja auch was erzählt hier von Distributed Net.
Genau, da hab ich mal noch ein bisschen zuhause geforscht, weil ich so ein bisschen gedacht hab, das wär eigentlich voll die Sache, die man mal so machen müsste, ob man sich da mal so reinhängen kann, den RAC5 Code irgendwie in CUDA implementieren, weil es sah alles so easy aus da. Und dann hab ich entdeckt, das machen die bei Distributed Net schon seit Ende 2007. Also seit dem CUDA rausgekommen ist, mehr oder weniger. Und dann hab ich ein bisschen, weil es gibt Pre-Release-Clients von Distributed Net, die halt CUDA benutzen. Also Distributed Net ist so ein Projekt, das gibt es keine Ahnung, inzwischen schon seit 10 Jahren oder länger. Die wollen halt RAC5 Schlüssel knacken. Und inzwischen sind sie bei dem 72-Bit-Schlüssel angekommen. Und ich glaub, für den 64-Bit-Schlüssel brauchten sie so ein paar Jahre. Und der 72-Bit-Schlüssel braucht ja natürlich 256 mal länger. Ich glaub, sie haben noch nicht mal 1% des Key Spaces geschafft, irgendwie durchzurechnen. Aber die schreiben immer schnellere Clients und passen das immer für die neuesten CPUs an. Und jetzt halt auch an CUDA. Und da war das Schnellste, was ich lesen konnte, dass eine 280 oder 285, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht mehr, GTX-Card hat, also von Nvidia. Und die schaffte 550 Millionen Keys pro Sekunde zu berechnen. Und ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass, glaube ich, mein MacBook Pro hier schaffte, glaube ich, 11 Millionen oder sowas pro Core. Das heißt, das Ding ist 50 mal schneller als ein CPU-Core.
11 Millionen pro Core. Du hast zwei Cores, 22. Und die machen 550.
Aber es war auch natürlich eine richtig fette Grafikkarte.
Aber 25 mal so schnell.
50. Ach so, ja, gut. 25 Mal. Klar. Du kannst jetzt auch rechnen, ok, du könntest jetzt irgendwie 8 Cores haben oder riesengroße Rechner. Aber du kannst das auch einfach mit der Grafikkarte machen. Und vor allem, die CPU ist ja dann noch frei, die normale kann ja auch noch berechnen, wenn du willst. Also da geht einiges. Und dann hab ich gestern, wurde mir noch gezeigt, gibt es bei NVIDIA halt so eine Webseite, wo das ganze cooler Zeug so ist. Und da gibt es auch lauter Projekte von Leuten, die da schon Code oder Sachen geschrieben haben. Also es ist alles halt grafisch meistens, aber es muss gar nicht grafisch sein. So wie bei Distributed Net ist einfach nur Key knacken. Und da gibt es halt schicke Demos mit 3D-Software und alles mögliche. Physikalische Modelle, die da durch die Gegend flattern. Und aber auch beschleunigte Quick Sort-Routinen, die dann natürlich nicht 50 oder 100 Mal schneller sind, sondern nur 10 Mal oder so. Und das kommt immer je darauf an, wie das Projekt halt passend ist zur Parallelisierung auf so einer Grafikkarte. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall alles ganz schick.
Sprich, ja, vielversprechend.
Vielversprechend, ja.
Ich bin gespannt, was in Snow Leopard überhaupt alles beschleunigt werden wird. Also, wovon ich sicher ausgehe, ist, dass sie das in QuickTime X einbauen. Weil, ich meine, wenn sie das nicht machen, dann werden sie schon blöd.
Ja, kommt halt auf an. Also, wenn sie das hinkriegen, ordentlich so einen H264-Encoder zum Beispiel, einen Cuda umzuschreiben, wenn das ordentlich parallelisierbar ist, dann muss man halt mal gucken. Ist ja auch alles mal nicht so ganz einfach.
Wobei sie das ja jetzt bei den letzten Macs sowieso schon... Ach so, mal geht das vom Encoder oder vom Decoder? Ja, aber der Decoder läuft doch jetzt bei den aktuellen Macbooks schon auf der Grafikkarte. Das, soweit ich weiß, ist einfach dieses H.264-Decoding ein Teil der Grafikkarte sowieso schon. Das muss sozusagen nicht erst noch generisch implementiert werden. Das können diese Karten einfach.
Schickst du die Daten einfach hin und dann...
Aber es gilt natürlich für alles andere. Es gilt für Encoding vor allem, was natürlich noch viel interessanter ist. Wenn sie halt einen OpenCL, einen H.264-Encoder implementieren, der halbwegs was taugt. Aber auch alles andere.
Quartz.
Also...
Krypto.
Firewall vielleicht.
Ich meine, das haben sie ja im Prinzip auch schon seit längerer Zeit fertig gehabt. Bloß immer wieder aus Kompatibilitätsgründen nicht enabled. Wir machen PDF direkt auf der Grafikkarte. Und ich hoffe, dass das jetzt mal mit Snowlapper dann eben auch wirklich kommt. Wenn sie dann sozusagen mit OpenCL auch eine klare Abstraktion haben.
Das ist vielleicht nicht so parallelisierbar, aber...
Warum sollte das nicht parallelisierbar sein? Ich meine, darum geht's doch.
Na ja, aber was willst du bei PDF richtig ordentlich schick parallelisieren? Also die Rede wirklich von Factor bis das größte, was ich gesehen hab, war irgendwie 450x schneller als auf einer CPU.
Bei PDF müsstest du eigentlich alles parallelisieren können, was sich eben grafisch nicht überschnallt.
Also so wie ich es gestern nicht verstanden hab, ist es schon am coolsten, wenn die Stretts, die da losrattern und arbeiten, wenn die auch alle gleichzeitig fertig sind, gleichzeitig neue Arbeit aufnehmen und wieder gleichzeitig weitermachen und das ist dann schon noch was anderes Paralleles als irgendwie in unterschiedlichen Bereichen bestimmte Sachen rendern, weil die sind halt unterschiedlich fertig und müssen unterschiedlich nachladen.
Gut. Wie auch immer.
Da ist es auch im besten Fall, wenn die alle den gleichen Code hochladen.
Aber selbst wenn es nicht wirklich parallel ist, solange es die CPU nicht belastet, dann ist auf jeden Fall schon was zu holen. Ich bin gespannt, wie heißt die Maschine dabei wird.
Und vor allem können sie halt jetzt eine API benutzen mit diesem OpenCL, die dann halt auch eine Beständigkeit hat über die nächsten Jahre und müssen das nicht immer wieder in irgendwelche Karten neu anpassen, sondern können das halt an eine machen.
Ja, wollen wir irgendwie hier in unsere Frage- und Antwort-Runde gehen? Wir haben ja hier noch so einen Block-Eintrag.
Ich hab auch eine Frage.
Oh, was denn?
Ich hab's nicht geschafft, Windows 60B auf meiner Kiste zu installieren.
Ist es denn gescheitert?
An allem. Also vor allem an Windows. Also das Windows installiert nicht, weil's nicht mit mehr als drei oder vier Partitionen klarkommt. Deswegen kann man das Bootcamp nicht benutzen, wenn man schon zwei Partitionen auf seinem Rechner hat. Weil's Bootcamp ist, eigentlich der einzige Job von Bootcamp ist, du hast eine Partition auf deinem Rechner, so wie der halt ausgeliefert wird. Das Bootcamp macht die Partition kleiner und hängt hinten ne Windows-Partition dran. So, ich hatte aber schon zwei Partitionen, hab die einfach ein bisschen kleiner gemacht mit Disk Utility. Und ne Windows-Partition hinten rein. Und dann sagt der Installer, und ich hab mal so ne Original-CD da, sagt der Installer von Windows hier, ne, das geht nicht, zu viel Partitionen mach ich nicht. Okay.
Aber ich mein, das ist doch relativ üblich.
Das sagt der Installer von Windows? Nicht des Bootcamps selber?
Ne, Bootcamp brauchte ich ja gar nicht, ich hab mir das ja selber gemacht. So, und dann hab ich gedacht, okay, installier's halt externe auf ne Platte. Hab mir so ne kleine Platte besorgt, hier so ein USB-Schnuffi, dieses Tri-Fu Zeugs, rangeschlossen, losgelegt und dann sagt, und Windows richtig von CD gebootet auch wieder. So wie vorher doch, hätte ich Native gebootet. Und dann sagt es Windows, nö, das geht nicht, weil davon könntest du ja nicht booten, weil es ist ja irgendwie hier per USB so ungefähr. Das sieht er irgendwie im BIOS nicht, das müsste ich mal einstellen und wenn das das dann sieht, dann könnte ich auch darauf installieren, sonst nicht.
Aber du hast sicher, also, braucht man nicht Bootcamp doch?
Ja, später nochmal irgendwie aus dem Grund, damit das dann welche Treiber oder ein Cene brennt, die Treiber macht.
Nein, nein, nein, das stimmt schon gar nicht mehr.
Das Bootcamp macht nur die Partitionen kleiner, macht dann eine Partition rein in den freien Platz und markiert die mit irgendwie Windows, blablabla.
Passt das nicht noch das EFI an, damit man die Bigos-Emulation beherrscht? Obwohl, wenn du schon gebootet hast von der CD, dann sollte das ja schon gehen. Und das mit der CD, das stimmt schon lange nicht mehr, weil das war nur in der Beta-Phase von Bootcamp, das ist einfach seit 10.05, seitdem Bootcamp Final ist, musst du einfach deine Leopard-CD reinschieben, DVD. Und da sind die Treiber drauf.
Ja, aber du musst nach wie vor die Treiber installieren, sonst weiß das Windows halt nicht mehr.
Aber soweit komm ich ja gar nicht erst. Also ehrlich gesagt, ich hab's bisher noch nicht mehr geschafft, XP überhaupt zu installieren, weil es sich vorher schon mal geweigert hat, überhaupt loszulegen. Und mir fällt aber langsam das Schmein.
Weiß nicht, also ich hab das halt nur einmal so gemacht, so wie es gedacht war, dass man eben nur eine Partition hat, plus eben das, und dann ging's. Also das machte mir allerdings auch alles einen sehr eingeschränkten Eindruck.
Also bei mir ging's problemlos.
Aber auch in der Konfiguration.
Auch in der Konfiguration?
Genau, und er hat aber eine andere Konfiguration.
Ich hab halt eine Partition zu viel.
Du hast eine Partition zu viel.
Ja, aber Windows muss garantiert mit, also dann ist die zu weit hinten, oder ich weiß nicht was. Also Windows kommt mit.
Was halt nicht geht mit Disk Utilities, Partition verschieben. Das geht halt nicht. Und ich meine meine scheiß Partition ist jetzt 450 Gig groß, da kannst du nicht schnell mal auslagern, das geht nicht mehr.
Wie, und was hast du, du hattest, hast du dann einfach drei Partitionen draus gemacht, oder was?
Na ja, ich hatte halt zwei, ich hab immer vorne eine zum booten und eine für die Daten und die ist halt riesengroß, der Rest halt. Also ich mach mal 30 Gig zum booten und hier, also hier zum booten 32 und der Rest irgendwie 433.
Ja.
So, dann hab ich die einfach hier kleiner gezogen, kannst ja irgendwie machen hier, siehst einfach hier die so kleiner und machst da irgendwie eine neue rein und da wollte ich dann Windows drauf installieren.
Warum hast du es nicht einfach mit Bootcamp gemacht?
Der macht das nicht. Bootcamp, wenn ich jetzt Bootcamp starte, dann sagt Bootcamp sofort, Bootcamp Assistant hier, wir können auch gucken, dass die Version stimmt, ich hab hier Version 2, wenn ich dann hier loslegen will, dann sagt sofort hier, the startup disk cannot be partitioned or restored to a single partition. Must be formatted as a single Mac or standard... Genau, er sagt mir, ich darf nur eine Partition haben, sonst geht's nicht.
Ach so, also es bootcampt quasi, Einschränkung.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil Windows auch mit mehreren Partitionen sowieso nicht klarkommt.
Na doch, natürlich kommt Windows mit mehreren Partitionen nicht klar.
Nee, im Windows Installer kamen irgendwie, das sind irgendwie drei oder vier Partitionen, oder mehr als, und das würde nicht gehen. Also ich hab halt nur zwei, aber es ist ja vorne noch die EFI-Partition oder wie auch immer, und das ist dem Windows Installer zu viel gewesen und da gleich seine Arbeit verweigert. Also mir haben auch schon Leute geschrieben, ich soll dann doch mal Vista probieren, weil da gibt's dieses Limit irgendwie nicht mehr, oder es ist größer oder irgendwie so, aber ich dachte, ich komm halt mit XP aus, weil Vista ist irgendwie so ein riesen Monster und ich wollt doch zocken und alle sagen, XP ist schneller zum Zocken. Und weißt du, warum ich in meinem Leben keinen Windows hier benutzt habe? Weil's nicht geht.
Naja, das Problem liegt ja...
Ich kenne sehr, sehr viele Leute, die unter Windows mehr als eine Partition und auch mehr als zwei Partitionen haben.
Aber auch mehr als drei oder vier?
Ja, das ist doch so, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Partitionen die dann haben, also mehr als drei brauchst du, oder auch mehr als zwei, also...
Es ist auf jeden Fall verfahren. Ich hab da wirklich überhaupt keinen Tipp. Ich hab das jetzt auch... Bei meinem Clean Install habe ich diese Windows-Partition auch wieder gelöscht. Weil, also das war so sinnlos. Und ich brauchte das eh nur, mit meiner Telefonanlage zu reden. Und jetzt werde ich mir vielleicht irgendwann nochmal...
Also meine letzte Idee ist, dass ich meinen Rechner nochmal aufschraube, weil mein Klappverschluss geht hier eh gerade nicht. Meine 500er-Platte rausnehme, meine alte 160er intern einbaue, also intern, dann von dem XP boote, dann ist die Platte intern, dann wird er wahrscheinlich auch drauf installieren können und wenn ich damit fertig bin, nehme ich sie einfach wieder raus und hoffe, dass ich dann per USB davon booten kann. Das ist nochmal so mein letzter Trick. Aber dann muss ich wieder alle 23 Schrauben aufmachen.
Tja, das sag ich dir. Tja, okay. Noch ein Wine? Nö, ne?
Jetzt sag ich schon Wine.
Das ist so Bits und so Sprech.
Kennt ihr das?
Wine?
Nein, Wine.
Dieses, äh, dieses, dieses... Damit man Windows-Programme nativ...
Nein, Wine. B-H-I-N-E.
Ach so, so rumholen?
Ja.
Klar, als World of Warcraft-Zocker kennt man sowas.
Man kennt es aber auch, Wayne.
Das ist mir Wayne.
Nein.
Das heißt, äh, das ist mir egal übersetzt.
Ja.
Das ist mir Wayne. Und es kommt daher, weil dies, äh, ich weiß nicht, wie es wirklich gekommen ist, aber es gibt wirklich einen Wikipedia-Eintrag dazu. Es kommt daher, dass man gesagt hat, wen interessiert's. Und dann wurde irgendwie Umgangssprache dazu übergegangen, Wayne interessiert's, also John Wayne irgendwie so, es interessiert keinen. Und seitdem heißt es nur noch, es ist mir Wayne.
Das wird jetzt bestimmt eine interessante Sendung über Internet-Meme.
Nee, ich bin ja auch schon fertig.
Ja. Ich bin halt ein bisschen schlapp drauf, ich gib's zu. Aber wir können vielleicht nochmal hier in die Kommentare gehen, weil da gab's ja so diverse hier zu unserer Live-Ankündigung. Ich sehe schon die Hälfte, können wir da nicht wirklich behandeln. Habt ihr das so ein bisschen vor euch?
Was denn jetzt?
Na, den letzten Blog-Eintrag bei uns in unserer tollen Webseite. Ich bitte dich. 21 Kommentare stehen da drin.
Das dauert hier. Irgendwer macht die Leitung platt.
Na du wahrscheinlich, oder?
Ist aus. Ist aus. Ich mach nix.
Ist aus? Ja, irgendwie hab ich ja auch schwankende Netzqualität in letzter Zeit.
Bei mir geht's hier gerade... Das Logo oben kommt noch und dann geht's irgendwie nicht weiter.
Ja, ich fürchte mal, das dürfte...
Du sein.
Das dürfte mein Problem sein.
Warum?
Kick it. Weil mir aus Gründen, die ich noch nicht kenne, während der laufenden Sendung der Atmation Server abgeschaltet worden ist. Da hab ich gerade eine SMS bekommen. Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich so ein bisschen ruhiger bin.
Abgeschaltet?
Ja, keine Ahnung warum. Ich hab eine SMS bekommen, wir haben den Server abgeschaltet. Wenn sie sich bitte an den Support... Im schlimmsten Fall hat irgendjemand böses sich auf diese Kiste draufgesetzt. Und hat zum Beispiel Spam darüber versendet. Ich weiß es noch nicht.
Achso, deswegen kommt jetzt ja auch nichts, weil es geht gerade nicht, oder was? Nicht weil die Leitung platt ist, sondern...
Also der Server geht, der Server, auf dem Mobile Max liegt, der ist davon nicht betroffen. Aber wir haben in der Seite, haben wir Atnation Werbung drinne. Oder zumindest den Counter. Und der Server, den haben die so dämlich abgeschaltet, dass er auf der IP nicht reagiert. Also es kommt kein Hostess-Down oder sowas zurück, sondern...
Ich kann jetzt also die Kommentare gar nicht gucken.
Warte mal, das kriegen wir gleich mal kurz hin.
Ja, wir sehen uns dann in zwei Wochen, hören uns.
Okay, also ich gehe mal so ein bisschen durch, ob hier noch was Spannendes dabei ist. Twitterrific, keine Ahnung. Ob wir eine Idee haben, warum Twitterrific auf dem Mac die ausschließlich aus alphanomierischen Zeichen bestehen, rumzickt. Alle meine Passwörter sind alphanomierisch.
Vielleicht meint damit nicht alphanomierischen Zeichen.
Weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht. Unsere Hard- und Software-Setups, wir sollen über unsere Hard- und Software-Setups reden. Was für Hard- und Software-Setups meint er denn?
Ich hab hier Macbook Pro, 4GB, 500er Platte. Was will er noch wissen?
Software Setup. Mac OS X.
Terminal, die Ente, Transmission, Webkit, Kolokwai, SSH.
Also wenn ich jetzt durch alle Programme durchgehe, die ich auf Mac benutze, dann wären wir in zwei Stunden nicht fertig.
Außerdem hatten wir das auch schon mal.
Ja, ja. Leute, wir brauchen hier auch mehr Meta-Anregungen. Wir sind hier echt keine Support-Line. Ich spring mal durch, ob hier noch was Spannendes ist. Können wir was Lustiges zu LaTeX sagen? Nein. Twitter-Spam? TheSentenceNoWord. Könnt ihr euch selber raussuchen. Och Mensch, was ist denn das hier? Spaß sollen wir haben. Ah, hier wird schon die TeX-Frage beantwortet. Das find ich schön. Man muss nicht immer alles selber beantworten.
Dann gibt's schon eine neue Transmission-Version in Beta 5.
Die Geräuschkulisse von Drobo ist irgendwie in Ordnung, wenn das Ding nicht gerade re-silvert. Was denken wir darüber, dass in der ersten Jahreshelfe iMacs mit Quad-Core-CPUs auf den Markt kommen sollen? Was denken wir darüber? Ich denke darüber, dass ich würde das toll finden.
Ich glaub ja da noch nicht so richtig dran. Oder glaub ich daran? Ich weiß nicht, ob ein iMac-Nutzer vier Cores braucht. Okay, aber die sind billig geworden. Also haut man sie natürlich rein.
Die haut man einfach rein. Und warum soll man die nicht brauchen?
Das kostet halt Geld, kostet Strom, müssen sie besser lüften und weiß tonnen. Wie naja?
Sie sind halt jetzt einfach drauf.
Außerdem wollen sie doch ihre Mac Pros verkaufen.
Die haben ja dann auch das Doppelte.
Die haben eh schon das Doppelte, deswegen.
Ja, die haben dann auch immer noch das Doppelte.
Nee, aber vorher hatten sie das Vierfache.
Vielleicht haben sie ja immer noch das Vierfache.
Das wäre mal eine interessante Frage, ob jetzt irgendwie die Mac Pros mal mit...
Mac Cores rauskommen.
Wie heißt das eigentlich? Quad und dann?
Okto.
0 Okto.
Puss. Sie.
Könnte alles sein. Wir hatten schon mal... Sendung mit höherem Anspruch und mit weniger abgelenkten Systemadministratoren.
Das tut mir sehr leid. Ich probier hier nur die...
Ja, du musst dich da jetzt auch drum kümmern. Das verstehe ich ja auch, das ist dringend. Wenn der Admin gerufen wird. Ja, das ist hier doch wirklich schön. Lalalala. Naja, so viele Fragen sind hier nicht wirklich. Wenn ich das sagen darf. Also... Leute, lass uns hier ein Ende machen. Wir sind abgelenkt. Oder?
Wenn du nichts mehr hast?
Ich hab nichts mehr. Ich hab nur noch so Kram. Da will ich gar nicht mehr weiter drüber reden. Das können wir auch später machen. Flash auf dem iPhone wird sowieso nicht kommen.
Da gab's doch jetzt News mit Adobe.
Da gab's so News, da gab's einen Adobe-Chef, der meint, sie würden dran arbeiten.
Das ist doch was. Chefin war's, glaub ich, oder?
Der meint sogar, dass sie mit Apple dran arbeiten würden.
Das gab's doch auch schon mal ganz kurz, nachdem das Ding rauskam.
Keiner glaubt ihm.
Ich schon.
Ja, ich glaub ihm das.
Doch, weil Adobe hat natürlich jetzt wieder so ein bisschen Schiss. Weil, wenn ich's richtig verstanden hab, ist doch dieses... Was ist das von Microsoft? Silverlight oder was? Die machen auch da so... Adobe muss jetzt schon ein bisschen lockerer werden, um das Flash zu verteilen. Weil das ja für die Zukunft...
Ja, aber was sollen sie denn an Apple bieten?
Für die mobilen Geräte Apple entgegenkommen. Kann Apple jetzt mal sagen, aber hier macht man ein bisschen abspecken, ein bisschen schneller und...
Ja, aber warum?
Also ich meine, das...
Na, sonst sagt Apple, nehmen wir als Silverlight auf und Telefon schicken.
Ach, Quatsch. Natürlich nicht.
Das wird Apple ja nie machen, wissen wir ja auch, aber sagen können sie das ja ernsthaft? Nein.
Das wird Adobe ihn ja bestimmt abdehmen. Nein, das ist Quatsch. Also ich hab ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht. Das Einzige... Also, ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt gerade alle danach schreien würden. So. Auf der anderen Seite ist es natürlich schon so, wenn man jetzt mit dem iPhone unterwegs ist und surft, dann gibt es halt so Webseiten, die haben Videocontent und den kann man nicht sehen. Ich muss sagen, mich interessiert eigentlich auch nur dieser Videoaspekt bei Flash. Also Flash ist für mich eigentlich wirklich nur interessant als Delivery für Video.
Weil sie es nicht ordentlich gemacht haben mit ordentlichen Dateien.
Wie ordentlich?
Na, ohne Flash, mit QuickTime, whatever.
Ja, das Problem ist, dass... Okay, pass auf, was man Flash zugute halten muss, ist, es ist nach wie vor die einzige Lösung im Web, wo sich Video und User Interface kombinieren lassen. Es gibt einfach kein System, wo du einem Video ein User Interface geben kannst. Und das ist auch der Hauptgrund, warum Flash so mega populär ist. YouTube, guck sie an. Wenn du so ein Embedded-Video hast, dann hast du ja mehr als nur das Video. Du hast einfach ein User Interface. Du kannst mit dem Ding interagieren, vor Zurückspulen. Hast da noch deine Menüs. Und was du auch noch anschauen wolltest, kannst du dir irgendwelche Embed-URLs direkt herauskopieren. Also da ist eine Logik drin. Da ist einfach so ein Fernsehoverlay. Der ist sinnvoll. Der ist allerdings auch dafür gemacht, dass man ihn mit der Maus bedient. Weil das ist alles tiny, tiny, tiny, tiny. Und ich glaub nicht, dass selbst wenn das Flash jetzt auf dem iPhone laufen würde, dass du mit deinem Finger irgendwas nennenswert bedienen könntest. Vor allem mit diesen ganzen Hover-Events und fliegt drüber, was halt einfach überhaupt keinen Sinn macht auf dem iPhone. Weil du hast da einfach keinen Zeiger, der über irgendwas hovert. Du hast entweder, entweder berührst du etwas oder lässt es gerade los. Das ist die einzige Form der Interaktion. Von daher funktioniert das Modell Flash nicht. Also selbst wenn Flash auf dem iPhone laufen würde, würde es nicht laufen.
Weil es alles so klein ist und man nicht sehen könnte.
Nein, weil man auch diese Events überhaupt nicht generieren kann, die das Flash vielleicht braucht. Weil es einfach Highlighting und keine Ahnung, also Funktionalität hat, die davon ausgeht, dass du ein User-Interface, also dass du einen Endgerät hast, nämlich eine Maus, die es einfach nicht gibt auf dem Telefon. Und klar, jetzt gibt es auch noch diese Flash-Webseiten. Ihr kennt diese Monstern mit 1024x768, wo der ganze Content in Flash ist, wo alles nur sich im Kreis dreht und so weiter. Ich glaube, die sind nicht zu retten. Und ich glaube, an sowas hat Apple auch überhaupt gar kein Interesse. Das Einzige, was ich mir vorstellen könnte, ist, dass Apple sowas wie so ein abgespecktes, irgendwie so Flash zwischen dem Vollflash und zwischen dem Flashlight, also im Sinne von, das ist das Einzige, was ich mir überhaupt noch im Ansatz vorstellen kann. Ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt wahrscheinlich ist. Wo halt auf der einen Seite Adobe sagt, das Ding kann nur mp4, macht kein Flash-Video oder so, also ist jetzt kein FLV-Codec irgendwie noch mit drin. Das heißt, es macht eben nur das, was Apple auch native auf dem iPhone sehen möchte. Und was ja auch einfach jetzt der Standard ist, alle gehen auf H264. Das ist jetzt wirklich vorbei dieser Videokrieg. Das ist jetzt nur noch eine Frage der Zeit, bis diese Transition noch abgeschlossen ist, aber es ist ganz klar, in welche Richtung es geht.
Naja, aber der Krieg geht ja auch immer alle paar Jahre von vorne los, dann wieder der nächste Codec kommt.
Na, ich glaube nicht, dass da jetzt so schnell der nächste Codec kommt. Weil man H264 eigentlich alles abdeckt, was du haben willst.
Ja, aber es geht immer noch besser.
Aber nicht so viel besser, dass das jetzt wirklich einen riesen Unterschied machen würde. Ich meine, du kriegst einen H264, kriegst du tiny, tiny mini Thumbnail-Videos in brauchbarer Qualität, die auch klein sind, und du kriegst halt HD mit irgendwie 1920 x 1080 und das ist auf jeder Blu-Ray-Disk drauf und das ist einfach mal...
Verstehe, verstehe.
Wenn da noch Verbesserungen kommen, dann sind das immer so kleine Erweiterungen links und rechts.
Du brauchst ja auch die Hardware dafür. Ich meine, du kriegst ja kein Silikon, was irgendwas anderes abspielt als H264. Das ist einfach drin. Also du kannst kein Embedded-Device heute bauen, sinnvoll.
So wie es auch so ein bisschen nach MP3 ist, war schon noch AAC oder MP4, wie man das nennt, gekommen, aber eigentlich, obwohl es schon inzwischen auch noch bessere Codecs gibt, wahrscheinlich, haben die sich nie durchsetzen können, weil es einfach gut genug war.
Ja, wobei ich schon glaube, dass es über kurz oder lang auch auf AAC geht. Also MP3...
Ja, das mein ich aber. Von da geht es nicht mehr wirklich weiter vorwärts, weil es schon gut genug ist.
Genau. Also das heißt nicht, dass es nicht noch verbesserte Codecs geben wird.
Ja, meine ich ja.
Verbesserte Codecs, also im Encoder-Bereich, da gibt es noch glaube ich viel Luft, bessere Encoder für HA264 zu bauen. Dass du einfach deinen Videokonent noch besser im Rahmen dieses Standards encoded bekommst. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sich irgendein anderer Codec in nennenswerter Zeit melden wird und sagen wird, jetzt müssen wir darüber diskutieren. Das ist jetzt vorbei. NW4 ist einfach der Standard.
Ich glaube in dem Zusammenhang, ich hab jetzt normalerweise nur so halb zugehört, aber trotzdem gehe ich meinen Sämpf dazu ab. Also ich glaube auch, dass Flash auf ein iPhone nicht kommen wird. Stattdessen wird das mit dem Video definitiv ein Problem, weil QuickTime musst du irgendwie einbinden und Windows Media Player musst du einbinden und Flash ist einfach eine Lösung, die funktioniert auf praktisch allen Desktop-Plattformen und darum ist es im Augenblick so unglaublich populär. Aber wie du schon erwähnt hast, Flash ist mittlerweile auch, kann nicht nur dieses dämliche FLV-Format, also dieses Flash-Video-Format abspielen, sondern auch, genau, MPEG4 mittlerweile. Und da kommt natürlich die HTML5-Initiative ins Spiel. Bei der es ein Audio-Tech gibt und ein Video-Tech. Und der Audio-Tech, der funktioniert in Safari schon ganz einwandfrei, baut einfach ein Audio ein, gibt eine Quelle an, zum Beispiel einen MP3-File, und dann spielt Safari dieses MP3-File ab. Und man kann das per JavaScript steuern und alles. Und genauso sieht es mit dem Video-Tech auch aus. Und das ist natürlich was, worauf Apple sich ganz gewaltig stürzen wird, auf die Ansage, also Videos könnte er dann so einbauen.
Was weißt du denn darüber, wie steuerbar ist denn das mit JavaScript? Ich meine, kriegt man dann dieselben Overlay-Geschichten hin, wie man sie derzeit nur in Flash findet?
Also man kann, du hast erstmal, packst du ein Video-Element rein. Also ich hab's mit Audio ausprobiert, ganz genau zu sein bisher. Und du packst so ein Audio-Element in die Seite. Das kannst du entweder so machen, dass es direkt beim Aufrufen der Seite abgespielt wird, indem du ein entsprechendes Attribut angibst. Oder du kannst per JavaScript drauf zugreifen. Und du kannst das abspielen, du kannst Pause machen. Ich glaube, du kannst auch vor- und zurückspulen. Also es ist schon so gedacht, dass du in...
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist ja nun wirklich 90er-Jahre-Funktionalität.
Naja, du packst aber diesen Audio-Tech rein und es spielt MP3s ab. Das ist bisher so, ohne irgendwas dazwischen gibt es da keine Lösung für.
Ja gut, aber das macht man heutzutage mit Flash.
Das macht man im Augenblick noch mit Flash. Aber wozu das mit Flash machen, wenn man es auch direkt in HTML machen kann?
Weil es einen User-Interface dazu gibt.
Zu Flash?
Nein, zu dem Audio-Clip. Du hast halt einen Pause, einen Start-Button, du hast einen Scrubber, du kannst direkt...
Den musst du aber in Flash programmieren.
Ja, na klar, aber das geschieht halt. Aber es gibt nichts anderes, worin das programmiert werden könnte.
Doch, ein JavaScript und HTML.
Aber wo hast du eine einzige Webseite in diesem Internet gesehen, wo das der Fall ist? Ich kenne nichts.
Bisher, dieser Audio-Tech ist in HTML5 erst definiert. Der ist noch nicht weit genug verbreitet.
Ja gut, er ist nicht verbreitet, aber ich meine, selbst wenn er nicht verbreitet ist, gibt es irgendeinen Browser und irgendeine Webseite, wo es dann die Webseite, wo dasselbe machbar gezeigt wird, wie Flash macht. Ich will die nicht bauen, ich will die sehen. Ich meine, wenn die das designt haben, dann muss es das doch auch irgendwo geben.
Also ein Audio-Player hat es...
Die fangen doch jetzt nicht drei Jahre nachdem sie mal über den Standard angefangen haben, mal an, da irgendwas zu machen.
Das muss erstmal implementiert werden in den einzelnen Sachen.
Ja gut, aber dann reden wir jetzt über FutureTech. Und das Ding ist, was ist heute? Und heute wollen die Leute halt das haben. Guck dir sowas an wie, keine Ahnung, The Daily Show. Da ist einfach dieser Video-Context das Herz dieser Seiten. Das ist ja nicht so, dass das so ein bisschen was siehst du wie Spiegel Online, naja hier ist der Artikel und dann kannst du auch noch das Video machen. Oder eben auch bei YouTube. Das ist einfach so das Herz. Und da haben sie sich halt so ein bisschen aus der Affäre gezogen, indem sie diese externe Applikation haben, die du da startest. Aber das ist ja auch nur partiell befriedigend. Andererseits, um jetzt nur Video aufs iPhone zu bringen, brauchst du auch diesen ganzen neuen HTML5-Mumpitz nicht, sondern dann kannst du halt einfach QuickTime ansprechen und dann hast du es halt auch.
Du könntest einfach einen Link setzen, auf dem es ein Pack-4-File ist, und dann würdest du in dem Moment das auf-Text-Wirdes oder das Stream.
Deswegen, ich bin auch auf deiner Seite, ich denke auch, dass Flash nicht kommen wird. Aber mir ist auch unklar, wie sie dieses Problem lösen wollen, dass einfach tonnenweise Webseiten da draußen sind, die sehr viel in Flash investiert haben und die vor allem mit Flash eine Funktionalität realisieren, wo es derzeit einfach noch nichts gibt, was das übernehmen kann.
Ich poste mal rasch über den Chat einen kleinen Link zu einer Demo-Seite von WebKit, wo du einen kleinen Videoplayer sehen kannst, der komplett in HTML und HTML5 programmiert ist.
Das Ding da?
Du drückst den großen Play-Button da mitte.
Und das Plus macht es größer. Das Minus macht es kleiner. Ja, na bitte. Antwort geliefert.
Und ich guck jetzt mal, was Firefox dazu sagt. Also Firefox unterstützt es.
Ein Poster-Attribut. Das ist nett. Also das ist hier auf webkit.org/blog/140 slash HTML5 slash media slash support. Wir sind ja hier in einem Audiomedium.
Genau.
Da muss man mehr sagen als dass wir nur irgendwelche URLs in Chats gepostet haben. Ja, okay, alles klar. Das ist in etwa das, was ich gesucht habe. Kombiniere, kombiniere. Ja, das wäre schön. Also mir war nicht ganz klar, wie weit die jetzt wirklich sind und was sie damit können. Aber im Prinzip ist das, du stimmst mir zu, das ist die Herausforderung. Ich meine, man muss dasselbe tun können, was derzeit Flash mit Video tut. Man muss nicht alles tun, was Flash kann, aber man muss dieses User-Interface für Video, das ist glaube ich das, was die Leute wollen. Und wenn es das gäbe, bin gleich fertig, wenn es das gäbe auf dem iPhone, stelle vor, jede Webseite, ist jetzt ein bisschen geträumt, aber man stellt sich nur vor, jede Webseite, die heute so ein Video embedded hat, würde das eben mit HTML5 in mehr oder weniger vergleichbarer Optik präsentieren können und das würde dann auch auf dem iPhone laufen. Kein Mensch würde mehr nach Flash schreien.
Definitiv nicht. Also ich sehe zwei Möglichkeiten. Was haben wir für Videos? Wir haben Daily-Show und sowas. Okay, die sind wahrscheinlich erst mal sehr, sehr dicht an Flash dran, weil die haben das ja gerade erst alles gebastelt und die müssen ja noch ihre Werbespots einblenden. Und die haben dann auch wahrscheinlich ganz furchtbare Angst, dass der heilige Content ja geklaut wird, den man sich bei ihnen auf der Webseite angucken kann. Und die werden sich wahrscheinlich erst mal nicht so leicht tun. Aber diese ganzen Webseiten, die jetzt nicht direkt YouTube sind, so wie Meo und Dailymotion und Sevenload und wie sie nicht alles heißen, die haben, wenn sie nicht schon eine iPhone-Version haben, in der sie einfach einen MPEG-4-Stream anzeigen, werden sie das Ganze sicherlich relativ zeitnah anbieten, dass man dann eben anstelle dem Flash-Content einen direkten Link auf das MPEG-4-Fall hat. Und damit das sich genauso gut auf ein iPhone angucken kann, wie...
Das wird ja auch schon teilweise gemacht.
Genau, das wird schon teilweise gemacht. Und Apple wird einen Teufel tun. Also, ich meine, Flash ist... Jeder, der mal mit Flash arbeiten musste, weiß, dass es... Also, ich kenn niemanden, der es wirklich mag. Also, es bietet... Es sieht schick aus und Kunden mögen es, aber jeder, der mit Design zu tun hat, du kaufst ein teures Programm, was so... eben Flash, was so mittelmäßig funktioniert, ist eher schlecht. Die Programmiersprache ist bar bei ActionScript. Das iPhone kann auch kein... Also, Tim hat mir gerade gezeigt, was auch passiert, wenn man die gleiche URL im iPhone eingibt. Da kann es noch kein Video-Content...
This is fallback-content. If you had video support, you would see some here.
Da kann leider auch noch kein Audio-Content abspielen, weil ich wollte das nämlich immer so ein bisschen haben, dass man Notification quasi machen kann, wenn irgendwas passiert innerhalb einer Webseite und das hat dann nicht funktioniert auf dem iPhone.
Und du hast das schon mal hier ausprobiert mit HTML5 und Audio.
Genau, das habe ich schon mal ausprobiert.
Mach doch mal einen Podcast-Player für den Mobile Max, den wir da einbauen können, statt das Flash.
Das wäre zum Beispiel eine schöne Möglichkeit. Eine ganz hübsche Idee. Ich muss mir noch mal die genaue API angucken. Ich hab bisher wirklich Seite eingebaut, Tag wird reingepackt, Play, Stop, Pause. Aber das wäre doch mal ein schöner Versuch. Und ja, niemand, also Flash ist...
It's not going to come. Ich glaube, Adobe träumt ein bisschen laut. Oder ich glaube, sie wollen allen noch so ein bisschen das Gefühl einflößen, dass es ja doch noch nicht vorbei ist.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass auch irgendjemand bei... Also es gab ja schon mal direkt, als das iPhone kam, das zweite, das Adobe gesagt hat, ja, wir sitzen dran, Flash auf dem iPhone zur Verfügung zu stellen. Und wir sind schon relativ weit. Und irgendwann, kurze Zeit später, kam der Stimente und ja, wir haben festgestellt, dass das technisch gar nicht möglich ist, weil wir können ja keine Plugins für Safari schreiben. Ist ihnen dann auch irgendwann mal aufgefallen. Also ich nehme mal an, da wird irgendeiner, dem irgendjemand in dem Gespräch gesagt hat, ja, wir probieren, Flash irgendwie aufs iPhone zu kriegen, wird das dann einen falschen Hals bekommen haben und auf der Pressekonferenz das Falsche gesagt haben.
Da ist glaube ich das Marketing einfach durchgedreht.
Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das genau der gleiche Fall ist, dass da irgendjemand sagt, das kann ja wohl nicht sein, dass es Flash nicht auf dem iPhone gibt, wir sitzen da ran, setzt euch mal ran und die werden gesagt haben, ja, ja, wir rufen nochmal bei Apple an. Ich glaube, dass es so siehts eher aus.
So, ich bin jetzt mit meinem Latein am Ende, hat noch jemand eine Gesprächsthemenkarte? Ja?
Hast du schon ausprobiert, dass du jetzt im Algenstore deine DM Songs einzeln updaten kannst? Oder hast du vorher alle gekauft?
Ich hatte schon vorher alle geklickt, von daher.
Und hättest du sie einzeln updatet? Keinen einzigen, den du weggelassen hättest?
Ich will keinen DM mehr auf meiner Platte haben.
Okay, wenn man die Songs eh hat, selbst wenn man sie so doof findet, man will die noch ordentlich, ne?
Ja, ich wollte sie einfach weghaben. Hab ich weggeklickt, jetzt weg. Aber...
Schon ein bisschen fies, dass man nur alle updaten kann, da haben sie ja schon viele beschwert. Und erst später dann nachziehen.
Naja, man könnte auch sagen, sie hören auf ihre Kunden. Naja, keine Ahnung. Aber dieses Feature war ja auch nicht neu, das gab es ja schon ewig.
Das alle nachkaufen.
Ja, dieses Update von Alben, das gab es ja schon seitdem. Na, wie hieß die erste Bude? Genau, nachdem Emi schon gesagt hat, wir machen kein DRM mehr. Ja, jetzt müssen wir noch das andere DRM loswerden.
Welches?
Na, das Video-DRM. Videos.
Hast du denn nicht mal gesagt, dass du Video-DRM für eine durchaus nachvollziehbare Sache hättest?
Ja, ich halte es für nachvollziehbar. Ich halte es allerdings trotzdem für nervig.
Im Mietbereich?
Oder im Kaufbereich? Ja, für so...
Sind die Videos, die man kauft, verschlüsselt oder haben die nur DRM, damit man nicht kopieren kann und so weiter? Das ist ja schon nochmal ein Unterschied mit diesem HDMI-Zeugs und so, mit dem Display.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Was ist da, ob das verschlüsselt? Ist das schon entgehackt?
Also bei den Songs ist ja so, die waren verschlüsselt und die sind jetzt nicht mehr verschlüsselt. Sonst ist ja das Gleiche. Da steht immer noch der Name drin, zum Beispiel, oder ein E-Mail, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Und nur die Verschlüsselung ist halt weg. Und DM bei den Videos ist halt die Frage. Ist das nur irgendwie markiert, als darf nicht kopiert werden und so weiter, oder ist das halt verschlüsselt?
Videos sind verschlüsselt, klar.
Na nur die Gemieteten oder auch die Gekauften?
Ich glaube sowohl die Gekauften als auch die Gemieteten, das ist so dieselbe Art Content.
Das muss ja eigentlich verschlüsselt sein, sonst müssten sie sich ja den Alarm mit dem, dass es nur auf Krypto, DisplayPort, Zeugs irgendwie da läuft. Sonst könnte man sich ja das gleich rauskopieren, das Video.
Ja, die wollen eine sichere Kette haben. Die werden nicht irgendwo ein Bit setzen, dieses Gläser und das Schlittschmetz.
Aber ehrlich gesagt ist mir auch so ein bisschen Schnurz. Also nee, das ist mir... Also eigentlich ist es Schnurz. Also folgende Gründe, weil wenn man es kauft, ist es sowieso meins, kann ich es abspielen, dann komm ich ja an den Schutz auch ran. Und als, sag ich mal, wenn ich jetzt der böse Raubkopierer wäre, ist mir auch Schnurz, weil die Dinger sowieso auf Pirate Bay kommen. Ob die da nun Krypto reinmachen oder nicht, das verhindert mal genau nix. Das Einzige, was da natürlich blöd ist, ist, wenn du irgendwann vielleicht doch mal keine App mehr hast, auch wenn es 20 Jahre sind, aber vielleicht, ich meine... Der Blaue Engel ist von 1930 und den will man ja auch jetzt 80 Jahre später vielleicht noch mal gucken. Wenn ich jetzt Filme kaufe, will ich die vielleicht auch in 30 Jahren noch mal gucken. Dann gibt es vielleicht keinen Mac mehr oder was weiß ich nicht. Dann will ich diesen scheiß Krypto nicht am Start haben.
Das fängt ja schon an, du brauchst ja nicht mal so weit in die Zukunft zu gehen. Das ist ja dieses Place for Sure, was Microsoft ja irgendwann mal begründet haben.
Ich dachte, das gibt es nicht mehr. Das hat sie ja von ganz alleine erledigt. Das ist aber scheiße. Ich will ja nichts kaufen und dann kann ich schon 3 Jahre später nicht mehr angucken. Was ist denn das?
Und ich glaube, noch laufen die Server, wenn ich mich nicht alles täusche, nach harten Protesten der Hützergemeinde, aber irgendwann nicht mehr halt. Bis 2010 glaube ich erstmal oder irgendwie sowas. Und danach kann man auf seine Musik reisen.
Ich meine, es ist ja schon schlimm genug, dass wir von einem Medium aufs nächste wechseln müssen. Also wenn du zum Beispiel eine DVD hast, die, weiß nicht, 10 Jahre, nimmt keiner mehr, diese riesengroßen Scheiben, wird einfach keiner mehr haben. Da wird man sich alles irgendwie auf so eine Platte kopieren in die letzte Ecke von so einer Exabyte-Platte irgendwie und dann liegt das da. Aber das macht man halt einmal und dann trägt man es immer so mit sich rum. Aber das würde halt ohne DRM geht es halt. Aber mit DRM geht es halt irgendwie nicht.
Was mich eigentlich am meisten nervt ist, dass das Handling einfach durch diese Personalisierung auch so schwierig ist. Also gerade wenn man von Einzelpersonen redet, dann mag das ja noch irgendwie gehen. Du hast einen Deinen Account, du hast so dein Zeug und fertig. Aber wenn ich jetzt mal in Familien-Kontexten denke, du willst halt einfach so einen Home-Server haben. Und ich will, was weiß ich, so für die Familie Content kaufen. Wenn ich eine DVD kaufe, dann, weißt du, dann kann die jeder in die Hand nehmen und abspielen. Aber wenn ich jetzt ein Video über meinen Account kaufe, dann liegt das halt in meinem Home so. Und da kommt es dann eben auch nicht raus. Also ich kann das nicht jemand anderem zur Verfügung stellen, der sich es dann anschaut. Ich kann es nicht auf einen Server packen und man kann es einfach woanders abspielen. Das ist einfach schon mal total beknackt. Klar, dann gibt es irgendwie Apple TV. Das kann dann irgendwie auf deinen iTunes zugreifen. Das kann dann irgendwie auf des einen oder des anderen iTunes zugreifen. Aber irgendwie ist das auch alles braune Scheiße, weil das muss dann auch irgendwie laufen, dieser Computer oder da sein. Und dann hast du es auf dem Laptop. Und wie kriegst du es dann irgendwie auf den Server? Und dann kannst du es nicht irgendwie irgendwo hin kopieren, weil dann hat es ja das Problem, dass es dann auch gemischt ist. Das eine hat der eine gekauft, das andere hat der andere gekauft.
Es sackt alles.
Es sackt alles. Es ist einfach egal, wie man darüber nachdenkt. Es gibt auf jeden Fall immer wieder irgendwelche Zäunen, in die du hineinläufst. Und das macht halt einfach keinen Spaß. Während das jetzt so bei normalen DVDs, so bekloppt DVDs auch sein mögen, haben wir einfach den Vorteil, die legst du halt einfach in den Abspieler und dann spielt er das halt ab, solange es sich um einen –nicht wahr? unabhängig von region code und so weiter aus ist.
Vor allem kannst du ja auch den DVD-Player holen von Hersteller deiner Wahl und nicht irgendwie unbedingt von Apple.
Genau. Und das, finde ich, ist schon noch störend.
Aber vielleicht lernen die das ja da auch so wie bei der Musik. Da haben die das ja auch gelernt.
Ja. Gut, das ist das, warum ich jetzt gesagt habe, jetzt müssen wir das da auch nur noch loswerden. Beim Verleih, wie gesagt, finde ich auch nach wie vor, ist nicht so schlimm.
Ist ja was anderes. Da habe ich es ja nicht für mein Leben gekauft, sondern dann gucke ich es an und danach ist Ruhe.
Genau. Und es ist auch so für den Moment. Genau. Dann lädt man sich das sozusagen direkt ins TV-Set, schaut sich halt diesen Blockbuster an und danach schaut man sich drei Jahre vielleicht nicht mehr an.
Ich auch nicht, ist ja abgelaufen.
Dann haben wir ihn auch alle gesehen und haben da irgendwie fünf Leute davor gesessen. Also da ist das irgendwie auch in Ordnung. Da gibt es ja auch Luste für Kaufware. Am Ende ist das auch kein Kaufmarkt. Also online Video. Vielleicht bleibt Kaufen tatsächlich eine Scheibe.
Aber von den Medien geht es auf jeden Fall weg.
Die Scheibe wird es nicht machen.
Brennen können wäre schon mal ganz gut. Ich meine, das ging ja bei Musik auch.
Das geht auch weg.
Was geht weg?
Medien.
Naja, so Medien haben wir auch.
Brennst du dein Zeug auf Medien?
Na, so Videos, wenn ich sie kaufe, würde ich das unter Umständen schon tun. Weil sonst habe ich ja dieses ewige Backup-Problem. Meine Datenbestände werden immer größer. Ich muss mir immer mehr Platten machen, bis jeder zu Hause ein Rechenzentrum hat. Ich meine, das ist auch kein wünschenswerter Zustand, dass man wirklich nur noch Türme von Terra und Pinaweiden platten.
Aber eigentlich würde mal eine Platte reichen, wenn du alle zwei, drei Jahre die nächste große Platte holst, dein altes Zeug da draufkopierst und...
Ja, aber das musst du halt auch erst tun. So eine Scheibe stellst du halt ins Regal und dann weißt du, wo sie ist und weißt, wie du rankommst. Und nach drei Jahren ist es fertig. Ich rechne nicht mit einem ungebremsten Siegeszug der Digitalisierung von Medien.
Ich rechne schon damit, aber auch teilweise zu unserem Nachteil. Also wenn man halt eben keine Medien mehr da hat, wo man schnell mal rausnimmt, rein in irgendeinen Player und Play und geht. Sondern man muss sich halt in der Zukunft immer mehr kümmern, dass irgendwie alles noch miteinander funktioniert.
Ich hab jetzt irgendwie drei Kisten mit alten CDs. Ich hab die bis heute noch nicht alle gerippt. Weil ich weiß, wenn ich das alles rippe, dann ist das eine signifikante Nachricht, dass ich das alles in der Hand habe. Das ist einfach eine mehrere, viele, viele Gigabyte, wenn nicht hunderte, na hunderte nicht, aber eine zweistellige Zahl an Gigabytes, ist das definitiv.
Also ich glaube ja, dass es bei Videos einfach in die Richtung gehen wird, da wird Streaming der Standard werden.
Nee, Streaming auf gar keinen Fall.
Da will ich fast wetten.
Also da habe ich meinen täglichen Terror hier mit irgendwie The Daily Show. Das gibt es nur über Streaming.
Das musst du ein bisschen in die Zukunft denken, das Netz wird schneller.
Das Netz wird schneller, ich habe hier 16 Megabit, ich kriege die Scheiße nicht gestreamt.
Ja klar, weil alles natürlich auch tagsüber, da kriegst du keine 16 MBit.
Ja aber ich brauche ja auch keine 16 MBit, um so einen kleinen Daumennagel die Videos zu...
Aber Tim, ich gucke mir die Daily Show auch regelmäßig über deren Webplayer an, das funktioniert wie eine Eins bei mir.
Ja, bei dir. Und bei mir geht es halt hier nicht in zwei, von zwei Versuchen geht es halt einmal nicht.
Liebe Mobile Max-Hörer, bitte, bitte helft Tim sammeln, damit er macht vernünftiges, wie es ihm kommt.
Ja, ich sag den, also Streaming ist ein Trugschloss. Das geht immer von einer Mindestgeschwindigkeit aus, die du so nicht vorfinden wirst über einen größeren Benutzerkreis. Dieses Progressive Download, das ist völlig in Ordnung. Ja, aber Streaming ist scheiße. Progressive Download funktioniert mit jeder Bandbreite, aber Streaming, wenn YouTube Streaming hätte, es wäre nicht auch nur ein bisschen so populär, wie es heute ist. Es wäre ein toter Dienst.
Vielleicht ist das Streaming noch nicht so schick, wie es sein könnte.
Das Problem bei Streaming ist, es geht immer von einer verfügbaren Realtime-Bandbreite aus.
Also ich meine, das ist ein...
Also Progressive, Hardtp ist auch nichts weiter als ein Stream, der besser gepuffert wird.
Doch, das ist was anderes. Es ist nämlich kein Streaming, es ist ein Download. Du lädst die ganze Datei in dein Widget und dann wird es abgespielt.
Oder schon vorher, oder nicht?
Oder schon vorher. Du willst ja nicht warten, bis du einen 5-Gigabyte-Film gucken willst.
Du kannst es während des Downloads schon abspielen, aber Streaming ist was anderes.
Nur weil das nicht abspeichert?
Nein, Streaming ist ein Realtime-Protokoll. Das funktioniert anders als ein HTTP-Download.
Aber du weißt doch, dass man durchaus bei YouTube von Streamen sprechen kann. Das wird aber getan.
Das kannst du vielleicht tun, aber es ist falsch. Es handelt sich nicht um ein Stream. Es ist progressive Download. YouTube ist keine Streaming-Plattform. Streaming-Plattform ist Ustream. Und meine Erfahrungen mit Ustream sind genauso. In Europa Ustream gucken kannst du einfach vergessen.
Was? Nein.
Das mag mit deinem einen Provider so sein, aber ich hab einfach in 99 Prozent der Fälle bei Ustream Probleme. Und ich hab bei Content, der von vielen Leuten gleichzeitig geguckt wird, hast du auch auf dem Server das Problem, dass du nämlich auch beim Stream...
Ich hab die Amtseinführung von Obama auf Ustream geguckt.
Ja, da haben sie auch bestimmt alle Leitungen aufgerissen, die sie gerade haben, weil sie wissen, wenn sie das verkacken, dass das dann am Ende ist.
Wie viele Millionen Zuschauer wird das gehabt haben, das dürfte wahrscheinlich das größte online live geguckte...
Ich verfolge regelmäßig Live-Video-Podcasts auf Ustream und ich sage dir, es ist ein Problem. Ich schließe ja nicht aus, dass das nicht bei dir... dass das bei dir funktioniert. Der Punkt ist, Streaming setzt eine Bandbreite voraus.
Streaming setzt raus, dass dein Rechner nicht schon wieder am Arsch ist, wie immer.
Was ist hier auf dem Land?
Die haben ein Megabit DSL.
Ein Megabit DSL.
Die kriegen ein schnelleres DSL.
Ja, und was ist, wenn dein Bit-Torrent noch parallel läuft? Und das ist wichtig. Dann musst du das halt alles ausschalten.
Genau. Und wenn du zwei Streams irgendwie angucken willst, dann hast du unter Umständen ein Problem.
Das musst du bei dem Progressive Download dann auch machen.
Nein, bei Progressive Download, dann wartest du halt einfach nochmal 30 Sekunden. Nein, das geht bei Streaming nicht, weil du bei Streaming... Nein, weil der nicht das ganze File puffert.
Ja, das könnte man aber.
Ja, aber dann ist es kein Streaming mehr. Streaming ist bei Definition ein Realtime-Versand. Mein Gott.
Ja, auch den kann man puffern.
Der wird auch gepuffert.
Ja, der wird gepuffert. Aber ich sehe ja, wie es gepuffert wird. Und weder bei Ustream noch bei Daily Show funktioniert das richtig. Ich meine, bei Ustream ist es auch ein Live-Feed.
Da kannst du nicht so liebig puffern. Die ganzen Apple-Keynotes hier und so weiter, die ja früher noch live gestreamt wurden, inzwischen werden sie nachträglich gestreamt, das sind auch alles Streams und das läuft doch wie eine Eins. Wer hat es bei der Letzte gesagt, ging auf die Bühne und meinte, wir haben jetzt aktuell schon 50.000...
Das läuft wie eine Eins, das ist bei mir auch nicht so. Bei mir schon. Ja, bei mir schon. Das hängt von deinem fucking Provider ab.
Welch Provider bist du? Und wo bin ich?
Was weiß ich, wo du bist? Dann bist du woanders.
Ich sagte, das liegt gar nicht am Provider. Das liegt an deiner Kiste, die immer überladen ist.
Das liegt nicht an meiner Kiste. Meine Kiste ist sehr wohl in der Lage, so ein blödes Daily-Show-Thumbnail abzuspielen.
Ja, aber nur weil du eine neu installiert hast. Ich glaube, du musst auch mal...
Nur weil dein DSL hier Scheiße ist.
Ihr übersteuert.
Ach jetzt, weil wir so laut werden wie er. Man muss im Zuhörer sagen, die hat uns gerade runtergerettet, wir werden jetzt zensiert. Das ist ja unglaublich.
Ihr habt hier rote Balken irgendwie. Ich muss die Kompression hochdrehen bei euch.
Außerdem könnt ihr uns alle gar nicht hören, weil das hier gestreept wird. Ist das hier ein Stream, was wir hier gerade machen?
Ja, das ist ein Livestream. Das ist exakt genau das selbe Problem. Leute schreiben mir, ich kann das in Afrika nicht hören. Ja, das ist so. Streaming setzt voraus, dass du eine Mindestbandbreite hast. Und wenn du... Lass mich das sagen. Wenn du recorded Content nimmst und du bietest ihn nur als Stream an, dann ist das einfach Panne. Ja, klar. Es gibt da einfach keine gute Erklärung für. Ustream ist eine Ausnahme, weil das ist ja live. Und du kannst live nur mal nur live machen und nicht per Download. So. Und ich sag dir, YouTube, wenn die auf Streaming umstellen würden, was sie nicht tun werden, weil sie sind nicht blöd, weil wenn sie es tun würden, würde sie einfach nur noch 0,01% der Einschaltquote haben.
Streaming ist zwangsläufig ohne Puffer? Oder ab wann ist es denn... Ab wann ist es Streaming?
Ein Progressive Download ist etwas, was einfach eine URL ist, was ein Download ist, wo du dem Server sagen kannst, und jetzt möchte ich nur noch diesen Teil laden, und dann kriegst du den, oder was? Mehr oder weniger ein Random Access, beziehungsweise kannst du von vorne bis hinten komplett runterladen. Beim Stream hast du ein bidirektionales Protokoll, wo der Client und der Server ein Protokoll redet mit einer Window Size. Die Window Size wird durch verschiedene Parameter festgelegt, aber du kannst dieses Window nicht überschreiten. Ist das überschritten, dann kriegst du keine weiteren Daten.
Also bei dem Progressive Download, wenn du in Afrika sitzt und deine Leitung ist zu dünn, dann musst du halt einfach da sitzen, warten, bis alles geladen hat, weil deine Leitung ja so dünn ist. Dann kannst du es dir angucken. Wenn das aber ein Stream ist und deine Leitung ist nur ein bisschen zu dünn, dann kann der Stream tatsächlich von dem Bild, also wenn es ein schlauer Stream ist, kann er von dem Bild ein paar Informationen weglassen, an dem man sagt, interessiert mich nicht, oder Blöcke, die verloren gegangen sind, die musst du ja auch nicht nochmal haben, weil du guckst ja eh weiter. Also der Stream kann sich eigentlich in schlechten Qualitäten noch viel besser anpassen, wenn du es dann live guckst. Natürlich nicht fürs Speichern, das ist ein Unterschied. HTTP ist eigentlich auch nicht gedacht, um es live zu gucken, um es abzuspeichern. Progressive ist eine coole Erweiterung, damit man abspeichert und guckt. Stream ist dafür da, weil man es nicht speichern will, man muss nicht alle Daten haben, du kannst auch in die Mitte springen, außer bei dem Livestream halt. Also es hat alles seine Nach- und Vorteile. Ich würde sagen, auch Stream hat seine Berechtigung.
Also Stream hat seine Berechtigung ins Live-Wissen.
Nicht nur fürs Live-Gucken, auch so.
Umsetzt mal hier, umsetzt mal, was ich mit Streaming meinte, dass es in Richtung Streaming gehen würde, also dass Streaming die Silberscheibe absetzen würde, dann ist mir wurscht, ob du das Progressive nennst, oder wie auch immer. Ich meine auf jeden Fall die Variante.
Das kannst du nicht so einfach so durchmengen, das geht nicht. Wie sagt man so? Du kannst es nicht so pauschalisieren.
Ich meine, das, was die bei dieser Voodoo-Box sagen, und das, was sie bei Apple TV sagen, und das, was sie bei Alben sagen, ich sage, das nenne ich Streaming.
Das wird die Zukunft sein. Abschließend übrigens nochmal, ich hab ja ganz früher mal ganz lange die Chaos-Radio-Sende mit dem QuickTime-Broadcaster gestreamt, und da kam, glaube ich, erst letzte Woche wieder mal eine neue Version, und diesmal haben sie gefixt, dass wenn man also wirklich Video mit Audio streamt, dass es dann auch in Sync bleibt, weil es war früher mal ein Problem. Obwohl du einen Livestream hattest, ging das Syncing so langsam auseinander. Ich hab's jetzt noch nicht probiert, aber steht drin, dass sie da was verbessert hätten.
Diese Software, die haben sie jetzt seit wann nicht mehr verbessert? Na... Seit sie diese released haben, haben sie sich verbessert auf jeden Fall.
Doch, doch, doch. Also zum... Es gab als... gab eine Intel-Version, die kam relativ schnell raus. Die war aber total im Arsch. Die wurde dann noch mal ein bisschen nachgefixt, irgendwann später. Und irgendwie, ich glaub sogar zweimal. Und jetzt halt mit der 153 nochmal. Und weil die 151 ging irgendwie gar nicht so richtig. Und jetzt...
Ja, aber so richtig featuremäßig hat diese Software nichts.
Nee, aber sie tut eigentlich... Das, was sie kann, tut sie eigentlich ganz gut. Also das ist wirklich auch so ein... Der Streamt ja zum... Also der QuickTime Broadcaster streamt zum Server, der das dann weiter verteilt an die einzelnen Clients. Und die unterhalten sich auch miteinander, weil da gibt's halt einen Rückkanal, der immer schön anzeigt, wie viel Hörer man gerade hat. Also heißt im QuickTime Broadcaster kann man die Anzahl der Hörer gerade sehen. Hab ich auch mal schwer dran rumgehackt und Patches eingerichtet, die dann tatsächlich aufgenommen wurden.
Wir können ja nochmal einen Streaming-Schwerpunkt machen in einer künftigen Sendung. Aber wenn wir jetzt... Jetzt haben wir's. Na, ich glaub schon. Ich bin durch.
Ist ja auch schon 20 vor 11. Ich weiß nicht, wann wir angefangen haben. Auf jeden Fall vor über zwei Stunden.
Ja, definitiv. Diese Sendung läuft jetzt schon fast drei Stunden, Leute.